welcome back to another episode of the
stronger by science podcast today's
episode starts off with a ton of recent
feats of strength followed by a Q&A
segment in which we discuss topics such
as fat free mass index and our genetic
limits for muscle growth pre-workout
nutrition how to build strength without
adding muscle and whether or not you
should use touch-and-go reps while dead
lifting that's followed by a research
roundup segment which discusses some
fascinating new articles about the
relationship between muscle fluid volume
and force the effects of protein intake
on bone health and high load versus low
load training after that we've got an
explosive update on the drama related to
some recent controversial research on
red meat and processed meat and then
Greg shares some tips for making the
perfect sourdough bread as always thank
you for listening and enjoy the show
[Music]
welcome back to season two of the
stronger by science podcast this is your
host Eric Trexler today I'm joined by a
special temporary guest host named Greg
knuckles thanks for having me back thank
you for joining me now we have a lot of
feats of strength this week last last
episode you know everybody took off the
holidays they decided just to not be
strong for a while but there is a huge
list of really impressive feats of
strength but before we get into that
Greg has an announcement yeah so for the
last I don't know year or so give or
take I've been sending out a list of all
of the studies that I find during the
monthly journal sweep of mass or for
mass so you know essentially I'm going
through give or take a hundred thirty
hundred forty journals every month to
find good stuff for mass and figure you
know if I'm already going through that
effort may as well not make other people
do the same thing and waste their time
so I've been sending out the studies
that I pull out to folks and so I've
been kind of like promoting that more
not really promoting but like letting
people know that that is a thing I do a
little bit more aggressively and so I
found out this month actually that there
is a limit on the number
of free emails you can send per day on
Gmail because the number of people on
the list that I send those studies out
to has now exceeded that number and so
that left me in a bit of a pickle
because I told people like hey if you
just want to sign up and get an email of
studies every month I don't want you to
have to also get marketing emails in the
process to get those and so if we
imported those folks to our Jaz a normal
email list there is a chance that at
some point when sending out a marketing
email I would forget to like deselect
that tag or cohort and then
unintentionally lie to those folks so
that doesn't seem like a good solution I
could just start another like MailChimp
account or something that I use solely
for sending out the study emails that
also is not a great solution because due
to the number of people I'd be sending
them to it cost like close to a hundred
bucks a month which I don't particularly
feel like pain just to do people a favor
so what I've come up with is I am just
publishing them on a page on the website
and if anything that's probably actually
a slightly better solution because now I
can host like the whole archive of
studies that I've pulled out over the
last like three years so anyway if
that's something that interests you if
you want to stay up to date on the
research and just I'll warn you like
when you pull this up there's no way
you're gonna be able to get through
everything on a monthly basis I don't
know one does it's like it's like 250
300 studies a month but you can go
through the list and see you know what
looks cool and interesting to you and
just save you some time of having to
track down all of those studies yourself
anyway so if you want to check that out
you can go to stronger by science comm
slash studies
- archive so stronger by science comm
slash studies archive but a - between
studies and archive I think most people
listening to this are aware of some of
the other just free resources we have on
the site so if you're a podcast fan
there
there's a database of all of the
questions that we've answered on on the
podcast there's also a semi complete and
comprehensive list of all of the
systematic reviews and meta-analyses
that would be relevant to strengthen
physique athletes and coaches I say semi
comprehensive because I've gotten a
little bit behind on Keeping Up with
that but it's it's probably got 90% of
them and yes so there's there's a lot of
good free resources on the site in
general and this is just another one so
if you want to go straight to the source
and check out a lot of the primary
literature I'm doing a lot of the work
for you like going through and finding
the the studies every month that you
know would probably be the most useful
and relevant to lifters so you can just
go to stronger by science comm slash
studies - archive and check that out
yeah I mean it's impossible to overstate
exactly how helpful that is like like
this is a really cool resource that
people can use it could save you so much
time and allow you to really stay on top
of what's coming out every single month
from these journals but like Greg said
if your ideas like oh I'll just work my
way through all of them you know
systematically that's gonna be rough I
mean real ah'd realistically you
probably could but it would border on a
full-time job yeah yeah cuz like this
month I think there's like 250 so that
would break down to like you eight point
three a day so if you're a typical
person and it takes you about an hour to
work through a study and check some of
the references and whatnot that would
literally be working an eight-hour job
every day for the month so like don't
pull it up and get intimidated and be
like oh to stay on top of the research
kind of I need to read all of these no
one's going to like you know pick maybe
like five or ten that look cool to you
try to work through them that'll help
you stay on top of the research better
than you know most things trawling
Instagram for information YouTube like
whatever like it'll be a good source of
information for you yeah I have to admit
you know when you go through and do the
monthly sweep every single month there's
probably five to ten studies that I flag
and I'm like oh I'm definitely gonna go
back and read that one very thoroughly
and they just go completely unread until
I actually need them like six months
later but it's still nice to at least
kind of have your finger on the pulse of
what's going on in the dough for sure
and I think everyone can forgive you for
the systematic reviews and meta-analysis
thing not being totally up-to-date
because I think exercise science and
nutrition recently realized you were
allowed to do meta analyses and that
shark has officially been jumped there's
like 70 metas that come out every month
it's it's crazy dude it's wild like if
you go through and look at the years of
the ones that are currently on the list
I think if memory serves it's up to date
through last January like I think I'm
approximately a year behind but a solid
half of them I'm pretty sure were
published in 2018 and maybe like four of
them were published before 2014 yeah I
took a class at UNC on meta-analyses
with Charlie Poole who's like he's been
doing meta since before anyone really
gave a damn about him so he's like
pretty a pretty big deal in the Cochrane
Collaboration and all that stuff and he
showed us a chart of the number of
published meta analyses per year in just
like any particular field it is just
absolutely insane the spike that's
happened the last few years but anyway
okay so we have a huge list of feats of
strength we probably ought to get into
those and it looks like starting out is
our boy julius back at it again yeah
like I always say every month or two
when there's a new ridiculous thing that
he does in the gym this is pretty much
just like the Julius Maddox watch at
this point I'm sure a lot of people have
seen this video already because because
it did blow up and for good reason but
Julius Maddox has now become the first
human to ever bench over 750 pounds it
was a gym lift but you know clean Paul's
abs
we destroyed it he's the type of guy
that does either just destroy a weight
or fail but even by his standards he
destroyed this harder than I've seen him
destroy most things so it looked like
there was still more in the tank but he
benched 755 which is three hundred forty
two and a half kilos that is higher than
his current world-record which is three
thirty seven and a half or seven hundred
and forty four pounds something worth
noting is that he set his record on his
second attempt in the last meet he did
and he didn't take his third because he
said he was feeling some PEC tightness
like potentially strain people myself
included got concerned like oh no he's
about to hurt himself like he's gonna
tear a speck you know the the legendary
800 is never gonna happen
but anyway seems like he is [ __ ] fine
and I mean this may not matter for
people who lift in kilos but he's ten
pounds off an 8 plate bench in pounds
765 that's crazy like if you deadlift
765 I don't care who you are and how big
you are that's a crazy number for
deadlift like that's that's a really
really impressive number even more so
for squats because people tend to squat
more than they deadlift not that many
people have squatted 765 he's getting
pretty damn close to benching it which
is just wild yeah I mean I as you
mentioned Julius is like one of those
lifters that his lifts look deceptively
easy but somebody sent me to this sent
this to me on Instagram and I watched it
and my first thought was if I had a
lifter who sent me that video and said
hey my third attempt went up I'd be a
little bit bummed that we left so many
pounds on the platform well I mean it
was a training lift yeah he wasn't going
for a true max I don't think right yeah
but but like the idea of like how much
he has left in the tank like if that was
my lifters third attempt I'd be like ah
we played it kind of scared with the
lift selection so I I have no idea how
high it's gonna go it's crazy I really
hope he gets 800
would be that would be so cool yeah okay
so moving on moving on to the deadlift
you you Ren or yang su Ren us a PL
lifter has been so I've heard rumors
that he's considering doing a USPA meet
just to allow for a whippy bar so he's
he's a very good dead lifter he's an 83
kilo lifter 183 pounds has always
competed tested so one would assume that
he's still drug-free posted a video
recently deadlifting 850 he's one of
those guys with like a super super hyper
efficient sumo deadlift we've talked
about him on the podcast before I think
he previously dead lifted something like
820
but yeah so 850 is getting close to
stupid type numbers so like I said you
ran at least for the last like four or
five years every mean he's done has been
tested no reason to believe he's not
still clean but just wants to play
around with a whippy bar which you know
tends to help sumo deadlift errs quite a
bit and the 850 it looked like there was
more left in the tank and the thing
worth noting is that the world record in
the eighty two and a half kilo class or
181 is 400 kilos by Dmitri nasan oov
which for my money honestly maybe the
most impressive deadlift record on the
books like I remember when I got into
the sport the the to deadlift records
that just kind of like stuck out like a
sore thumb because they were so much
crazier than everything else was edy
cone had pulled 859 at 198 and 903 at
220 and nasan oov has pulled
close to 900 at 181 now and for my money
Kohn's 859 was at 198 was a little
better than his 903 and 900 but he's now
like beat that pretty convincingly so
you you Ren is
is closing in on edy cones old 198
record at 183 and is also closing in on
NASA knobs 400 kilo record at 181 if he
managed to pull that off that would be
wild cuz like I said I I think that that
is still the most impressive deadlift
record on the books and NASA knov is not
a tested lifter and it's also if he put
if he even put something in the
neighborhood of like 848 50 on the books
it would also be crazy because to
contextualize how far ahead NASA nob is
from everyone else in that weight class
so he's dead lifted 881 at 181 the
second-best in that weight class is John
hack in his best in contest is $7.99 so
like NASA naw has like 982 pounds on the
rest of the field and you you Ren looks
like he's closing in on that so if he
can put up anywhere in the mid-80s wild
and more kind of like lightweight
deadlift news Matthew I think that's
pronounced aramony aramony
had a gym left dead lifting a what
looked to be a quite comfortable 305
kilos which is 673 at a body weight of
66 kilos or 145 pounds that is also like
seven seven and a half kilos over the
current world record in his weight class
which is 298 by Hasan L Becky D so so
kind of comparing you use gym lifts and
Matthews you you Ren's best deadlift and
competition I believe is 749 that's on a
stiff bar and I've heard he has grip
issues I don't know if that's the case
or not so like the numbers he's hitting
in the gym now are way above anything
he's previously done in competition
Matthew aramony has gone to 90 in
competition before so the 305 gym lift
is
- far above that and he's proven he can
pull huge numbers on the platform before
if he is able to hit 305 and a meet that
would beat the tested record in his
weight class which like I said is 298
and it would also break the untested
record which was just set a couple
months ago which we talked about on the
podcast three hundred three kilos by
Michael Estrela so anyway in this is
another one where you should you should
check out the video because it is just
just a buttery smooth hyper efficient
sumo deadlift which I know some people
don't like sumo but like they're dumb I
think a well-executed sumo deadlift is a
thing of beauty and he has absolutely
tremendous technique moving on there was
there was a lift that kind of flew under
the radar which I think may be a
harbinger of things to come
so me haole Chinese lifter spotted four
hundred and twenty kilos or 926 pounds
at 275 for 125 kilos that is the number
three all-time squat in that weight
class behind only Sahir and Erik
Lillibridge one note I don't know what's
going on with zaheer these days he said
he was gonna squat five fifty haven't
heard much from him in the last 18
months hope he's doing well 100% the
most entertaining lifter ever his
Instagram presence [ __ ] fire is a
here I hope everything's well hope
training is good but anyway so me haole
number three all times squat in that
weight class he's only 23 years old so
that sets the all-time junior record in
that class but the thing that's the most
notable about it I think is that he is a
Chinese lifter and China China may be
about to just destroy the sport of
powerlifting but like in a super cool
way so this lift was posted on borscht
echoes Instagram
account and Boris said that powerlifting
is majorly on the rise in China which I
don't have a reason to not take his word
for it and for anyone who's paying
attention China is doing really really
well in weightlifting these days after
not being traditionally a powerhouse
like they they came into the sport
started winning medals I think like some
in the early 90s but kind of around the
turn of the 2000s once they had a full
generation of lifters to really work
through that whole system
they just started churning out medalists
left right and centre there's a lot of
state support for weightlifting and they
also have more humans on the planet to
find talent from so if if they decide
that powerlifting is next and even if it
doesn't have state support but just you
know people into physical culture
generally in China decide hey
powerlifting is cool we should do this
one that would be good for the sport
because it would be a huge influx of
just lifters period but then - I mean
you know you already got a guy setting
the all-time junior record in the squat
275 there very well could be you know a
handful of genetic anomalies in a
country of 1.5 billion people that's
that's very possible so yeah I hope it's
a harbinger of things to come and that
we see a lot of big lifts out of China
in the near future I think I only have
three or four more left trying to work
through these efficiently next one
moving back to the deadlift is Sergey or
Sergey feta Cinco deadlift is so he
posted a video of himself dead lifting
to 90 or 693 pounds for a for a double
so he competes in the 59 kilo class
which is a hundred and thirty pounds
little guy I've not met him but I've
heard he's like four foot six
so like super super tiny and if you
watch the video it will be obvious how
small he is just comparing like the
height
of the plates to the heights of his body
but just to contextualize how crazy that
is
and so one thing I'll note for when I
talk about deadlifts that people perform
in training I'll note whether they're
wearing straps or not because for some
people it doesn't matter they have a
good grip and they just train with
straps to not beat their hands up
other people do have a pretty strong
history of pulling way more inch straps
than they can without due to grip issues
so someone we've talked about on here
before several times instrum is Jamaal
browner who he's pulled somewhere in the
neighborhood of 400 kilos I believe
without straps but has gone like a
thousand pounds and above with straps
seems to be working out his grip issues
but that's something that's historically
hindered him feta Cinco is a guy who is
massively limited by grip strength
because on account of being like four
foot six he has really really tiny hands
and so you know his deadlift number for
the day is the highest number he can
grip for the day and that's you know
that's just the game for him but you
know lifting 290 for a double with
straps shows where his actual pulling
strength is and it's it's pretty wild in
context so that's it's like twelve and a
half kilos over the current raw record
in that weight class which is two
seventy seven and a half by Richard
Hawthorne it's also over the record at
sixty kilos which is you know the
comparable weight class and non IPF
Federation's that's two hundred eighty
six by stuart jamison so he lifted four
kilos over that for a double and then
like even a little bit crazier is the
record and single ply at sixty kilos is
310 by lamar can't which is six eighty
three point four and being able to pull
a fairly smooth double at 290 would kind
of project out a max somewhere in the
low 300s maybe 305 possibly 310
so that's actually a lift that's
comparable to the mark and which like if
you know anything about powerlifting you
know Lamar Kant is the god of the
lightweight deadlift so I mean obviously
dance is better because he did it
without straps but even to be in that
same stratosphere is absolutely wild
feda cinco is one of those guys who I
feel like probably isn't discussed
enough so a few episodes ago I talked
about Yaroslav elec and how he is
arguably the goat of powerlifting he's
won like 15 straight IPF World
Championships just lost this year for
the first time in international
competition since like 2001 or something
absolutely incredible but a lot of
people don't know about him he doesn't
get talked about enough Fanta Cinco
isn't quite on that level but he's
fairly close to it just generally
absolutely savages everyone in his
weight class people know him as a
fantastic all-around lifter if they do
know about him but you know because he's
so good all-around I think his deadlift
strength does get overlooked from time
to time so just kind of wanted to
highlight that and then let's see moving
on to a non power lifter Daniel stall or
stall
he's a Swedish discus thrower several
people sent me this video which like I
feel like a lot of power lifters
wouldn't appreciate this video quite
enough for how crazy it is but it was
[ __ ] crazy
so this guy's a discus thrower dead
lifted 350 kilos or 771 for what looked
to be a pretty comfortable set of five
and the reason I say I don't think
people would appreciate this quite
enough is like he was pulling sumo and
he had like kind of iffy technique not
like injurious technique but just like
the bar was getting out in front of him
you could tell that he wasn't locked in
super tight
and if you've messed around with a sumo
deadlift much you know how much like
really really getting your technique
locked in and dialed in just how big of
a difference it can make and if you
watch this video he doesn't have like
crisp picture perfect sumo deadlift form
he's just using just raw force to get it
up which is generally not advisable for
the sumo deadlift but still did a very
comfortable set of five at 350 kilos so
like on one hand I would love to see
what he could do if he transitioned into
powerlifting and got a technique coach
he I mean I could see him putting up
some absolutely absurd number on the
other hand he is arguably the best
discus thrower in the world right now so
he's not gonna do that quick little
aside about discus is Daniel stall is
the reigning world champion in the
discus he won worlds in 2019 he also has
the longest throw since 2009
he threw 70 1.86 meters and this past
year he actually fouled on a throw like
he stepped over the line on a throw that
went somewhere in the neighborhood of 73
or 74 meters since he fouled it they
didn't measure it out but the reason
that's noteworthy is the world record in
the discus is seventy four point oh
eight meters and that record has stood
since 1986
one of the things we've talked about on
the podcast before is like everyone just
assumes that athletes are getting better
in every sport and records are falling
in every sport but regardless of what
you think about drug testing in Olympic
sports now it's better than it was in
the 80s in that like athletes do get
tested sometimes and can't just blast
all of the gear they want year round
forever so like for a fair amount of
sports there are records from the 80s
and early 90s that are still in the
books that people haven't really even
challenged and discus is one of them and
so Daniel Stoll looks
to be someone who could potentially
challenge the the discus world-record
which hasn't seriously been done since
2006 so anyway he's not going to
transition to powerlifting but it would
be cool if he did
okay so finishing up last three I
realized this is the longest feats of
strength ever but whatever people just
took time off being strong over winter
break and now they're back to being
strong again so there's a lot john hack
broke the all-time world record at 90
kilos or 198 traditionally competes at
82 and a half kilos or 181 I don't know
if he was planning on going 198 this
mean and just didn't cut or whether he's
198 forever now but if it's the latter
he seems pretty comfortable in that
weight class cuz he like I said did his
first meet broke the all-time world
record total 932 and a half or two
thousand 55 pounds that breaks the the
world record with knee wraps by 15
pounds and he competed in sleeves so
yeah he's pretty much made the 181
classes [ __ ] and in his first attempt
at the 198 class it is also now in fact
his [ __ ] so props to him
let's see second the last one gonna save
in my opinion the best for last
arias 10 who is a female single ply
lifter benched 225 at sub 84 kilos so
225 is what like 496 pounds that's 12
and a half kilos over her own world
record she did that in the gym but you
know she's an IPF lifter everything
looked very locked in very much like it
would be replicable on the platform so
yeah she's the best in the world in that
weight class and looks to be pretty
close to the 500 pound barrier in the 84
kilo class which is pretty wild and then
my personal favorite
another guy we've talked about on feats
of strength before 17-year old Jackson
Powell last time we talked about him he
had I don't know he'd squatted like 765
for a double in the gym or something
like that and like folks all over the
Internet it was shot from like a shitty
angle it was like behind him it was like
behind kind of like obliquely and above
which is the worst angle imaginable to
see depth but people were like ah he's
cutting it super high like that's not
legit at all
anyway he did a meet he squatted 8:32
and it got passed and it was
convincingly deep from a front angle in
total 1856 so yeah kids [ __ ] strong
that's the biggest squat by anyone 17
years old by by about 30 pounds and it's
also about 90 pounds over the biggest
total anyone's hit at that age I mean
he's he's close to a 1900 total at 17
which is wild so anyway I think that's
[ __ ] cool that kids so strong and you
should watch the video too because like
he very well may be he may be like the
squat version of of Julius Maddox where
he either just blows it up or misses I
mean that's a possibility I guess but it
looked like he had a lot in the tank on
his 8:32 and his third attempt deadlift
as well looked like he had a lot left in
the tank so I mean kids already crazy
strong but he has a very bright future
ahead of him in this board yeah it's
funny that you mentioned the that video
angle how you said it was like to the
side kind of behind and from above so
it's really hard to tell so there is a
video of Steffi Cowan recently squatting
for 62 at a body weight of about 125
from a mono lift with wraps but it
sounds like it had the same kind of
angle it was like behind to the side
elevated and so a lot of people were
like oh that's really high I couldn't
really tell cuz the angle was so
ridiculous for the the video
but I did see that recently she squatted
like 444 three with like really good
depth from a good camera angle so like
the idea that she could get 462 for one
is not particularly surprising you know
anything from above and behind it always
looks high yeah like I've seen maybe
three squats ever which it didn't look
super high from that angle and they were
all from weight lifters just like ass to
grass or it's like well you know you're
when I look at how it looks like your
thigh is maybe it looks like you're
slightly below parallel but I see that
your ass is literally in contact with
your shoes okay so I will take that as
evidence that you are well below
parallel but yeah anything even within
sniffing distance of parallel if you're
two inches below parallel from a camera
angle that's like behind slightly to the
side and above hip level it's gonna look
like six inches high yeah yes the the
video did look kind of high but I think
it was purely just a kind of an optical
illusion but in any case if you're
putting 462 on your back at 125 that's
pretty wild
I saw some of the comments on that
people were like huh ego lifting it's
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
you know she competes she's pulled she
has like the second she has the
second-highest wilkes all-time right I'm
not sure I think she does she's strong
as hell if she doesn't have an ego she
ought to get one cuz she's a freakin I
mean she's a beast so I if she's gotten
that strong from ego lifting like what
the [ __ ] can you say it's clearly
working for ya yeah that stuff kills
again alright so let's move on we're
gonna do some q and a's today first q a
question comes from grant you want to go
ahead and read me into that yeah so
grant asks a few episodes ago you guys
mentioned something about fat free mass
index or FFM I it made it sound like the
notion of 25 being some kind of upper
limit was a bit silly yes we did that is
true I agree in that genetic outliers
exist
I was wondering what percentage of guys
you think could break that barrier
naturally I personally don't know of
anyone that I'm confident is natural
anywhere close to 25 for a reference
what is Eric's estimated FFM I in lean
condition what about the other Eric
which is Helms yeah so I'm gonna start
out with the end there like I don't know
what my fat free mass index is I don't
like I've never bothered to calculate it
because I know I'm not even close to
what anyone would consider a natural
limiter so like it's never been of
interest to me because I know I've got a
lot of room to go it's same thing with
Helms I don't know what is fat free mass
index is it's it's probably kind of high
cuz he's kind of tall for a bodybuilder
that there is kind of a positive bias
for taller people but in any case let's
get to some of the other aspects of the
question so what percentage of people
could attain a fat free mass index above
25 there's a couple studies and athletic
populations we can use to look at some
of those percentages so my lab group in
2017 published a paper we looked at
division 1 and division 2 college
football players in the division 1
athletes 31 percent of the sample had
fat free mass index values above 25 so
nearly 1/3 in the division 2 sample 18
percent had fat free mass index values
above 25 and division 2 football for
those who aren't familiar with American
football it's not particularly elite you
know if if you've got someone going from
a division 2 football team and having
like a notable kind of high profile
professional career in the sport it is a
bit of a feel-good story
it's kind of like oh wow it kind of made
it up from a d2 team and kind of you
know did something and it's generally
someone who is a massive late bloomer
where yeah you know by the time they're
in their sophomore year playing d2
they're like just [ __ ] physical
specimen but they you know Hannon hit
their growth spurt yet by 18 when
colleges were recruiting yeah it's
almost exclusively a story like that
yeah so if
are gonna come into this and tell me
that you know a fifth of Division two
football players are on steroids because
the stakes are simply that high I'm
going to laugh in your face I'm not
going to entertain that concept
whatsoever it's ridiculous so there was
another study by courier at all in 2019
that looked at fat free mass index in a
variety of collegiate athletes I can't
remember off the top of my head if it
was Division two or Division three but
but it definitely wasn't Division one
and they found that three separate
sports had a 75th percentile cutoff that
was above 25 for fat free mass index so
for football weightlifting and rugby so
it kind of makes sense for those sports
they generally favor people with a
reasonably high degree of muscularity
they also found that three additional
categories had a 75th percentile cutoff
that was above 24 so track and field
water polo and then just all of the
athletes combined into a big group I
mean that's not fair
everyone knows water polo players are
notorious mass monsters that is true
absolutely now a lot of people when they
talk about these fat free mass index
things like yes for the the statistics
from football players football players
do tend to have relatively higher body
fat levels that does generally allow you
to push your fat free mass index value a
little bit higher so if you look at like
sumo wrestlers will see values well into
the the mid and even high 30s right I
mean it's that there's definitely
something to the body fat component but
one of the things that I find really
fascinating about about this question is
that everyone's like so what percentage
of people can be absolutely shredded you
know on stage bodybuilding type
conditioning with a fat free mass index
above 25 I think you have a way better
shot getting your fat free mass index
228 than you do of ever being in contest
shape like honest to god the percentage
of the population that's going to get
there I think is astronomically larger
for having a fat free mass index of 28
at any body fat compared to just the
general premise of getting into
bodybuilding shape I mean the other
thing I'll say as well is like the
caveat of well only 25 was only meant to
be a limit for people who were shredded
on the bodybuilding stage there's no
basis for that that's just [ __ ] that
people made up because when people were
proposing a limit of 25 there were you
know hundreds of examples to the
contrary and folks would be like oh but
they're not shredded the actual study
that people cite to get the limit of 25
Curie at all 1995 says that like if
people are quite fat maybe they can get
above and in FF mi of 25 but if you
actually look at their sample that they
used to derive what they presented as a
limit of 25 the the body comp was and I
should have pulled this up but I want to
say for the drug the drug free cohort
body fat percentage was like 12 and a
half plus or minus 4.5 percent body fat
so I mean even within one standard
deviation which is like normal [ __ ] if
you're proposing that as a limit you
also have to take on board that it
should apply to people up to at least 17
percent body fat and if you're just
saying that it the research says it only
applies to people in stage lean
condition I'd say show me your reference
because there's not one like that's just
something people made up after the fact
yeah so I mean listen it's tough to get
in stage condition period it's even more
tough to be in stage condition and have
a ton of muscle but the idea that being
above 25 is some kind of super rare
thing I just don't think the data
support that contention especially if
you give yourself a little flexibility
with what body fat body fat range you're
considering it's not that rare to see
relatively decent football players get
into the 28 29 and 30 range it's just
not and we're talking about at you know
a Division one program that's by no
means you know attracting all the the
most elite you know I mean there's what
how many division one football programs
are there like a hundred and twenty-nine
yeah like that so I mean we're talking
about a large large
large number of people in one singular
sport that are that are floating around
27 29 no problem
without being you know 35 percent body
fat it's not like this is all sumo
wrestlers so I just don't see the data
supporting this contention that it's
hard to be fairly lean I mean no one
gets contest ready no one does unless
you're a pro bodybuilder but you can be
pretty fairly lean and comfortably above
25 and I think the data is far more in
support of that and then against it and
then you even look at the quarry paper
back in was it 95 yeah when they looked
at the the mr. America winners from 19th
I think it was 39 to 59 yeah but they
looked at and we're dude the the
training and nutrition methods in 39 to
59 were not great they really weren't
and they were still finding examples of
plenty of people over 25 in pretty damn
good shape
and so one of my main things like the
other thing just to note about that
further is that the mr. America winners
in very few circumstances were they at
their all-time biggest when they won the
mr. America because John Grimek won I
believe in 42 and 43 or 43 and 44 one of
the two but his second win he was just
so much better than everyone else that
they were like oh we need to institute a
rule that people can only win mr.
america once because john Grimek is just
going to completely cannibalize our
competition for the next decade so I
mean like yeah those are the FFM eyes of
the mr. america winners presented in the
quarry paper but you know that is just
what they're FFM I was at the time that
they won if they kept raining like they
probably kept getting bigger after that
as well so we don't even know that that
was the peak muscularity of those
particular mr. America winners much less
the peak of theoretical human
muscularity right and so whenever I have
this conversation I always concede
listen it probably does take some very
solid genetics to be at 25 and to be
super shredded
and if you're gonna be at 25 and super
shredded it means when you're bulking up
you're probably gonna have to be
comfortably above 25 you know you're
probably gonna be up into the into the
higher 20s which we've seen many many
many times and people that aren't even
bodybuilders these are just people who
want to be strong so they can be good at
football right so if they train for
bodybuilding they'd be higher you would
have to assume right I mean I think one
would certainly think a pretty fair
assumption right I mean it so in any
case I always concede yeah it probably
takes some decent genetics but that also
brings brings us to the idea of if it's
a low probability thing how rare does
that really make it for an individual to
get there you know what I mean so the
idea are we talking about a low
percentage chance or are we talking
about an absolute unicorn that just
defies our imagination in terms of
genetics and I think you have a really
sensible way of looking at that
statistically yeah so I wrote some
articles about this back in the day I
actually wrote several articles about
steroids and the one where I go through
all of this is the most stats heavy and
consequently the one the fewest people
read but anyway when you go through and
look at the studies so like fat fat free
mass index is not a common thing for
studies to report but of the ones that
do for a sample of people who aren't
University athletes because because one
could say like oh well even d2 football
players probably do have better genetics
for getting big than people in the
typical population which which is a very
fair assumption to make
you know the d2 athletes as Eric said
aren't unicorns but they are probably
more physically gifted than the typical
person definitely so if you go through
and look at studies that do just take
normal gym going populations and that do
report fat free mass indices you tend to
see that fat free mass index of just
day-to-day lifters in Jemez with two
plus years of resistance training
experience somewhere in the neighborhood
of 22 plus or minus 2 so like fat free
mass index of 22 isn't particularly big
but plus or minus
- that's a fair amount of variability so
within one standard deviation you know
you're somewhere between the twenty and
a twenty four which you know twenty it's
not big but people will probably be able
to tell you lift maybe twenty four is
quite big but it's just one and a half
standard deviations from the mean which
still isn't an outlier by any means at
that point you're at twenty five and so
what one and a half standard deviations
from the mean means in a probability
sense is that's roughly 93rd percentile
it's like ninety three point four
percent I'll something like that which
means that you should anticipate fat
free mass index of twenty five being
achievable by one out of every fourteen
or fifteen people you know which is
certainly worse probability than a coin
flip but also isn't unbelievably rare
there are some caveats to this of course
so one is that I would assume that even
just like people who you know stick with
lifting for two years but are just in
the normal gym going population they are
probably a little bit more genetically
gifted than just folks in the general
population on average mostly because you
know if you take up lifting and you get
no gains from it and don't get any
anything out of it you're probably not
gonna stick with lifting very long so I
do think that people who stick with
lifting for a few years just due to that
natural filter do have at least slightly
better than average genetics for getting
big but on the flip side
these studies don't recruit people
specifically who are at their genetic
limit of muscularity so I think those
two things kind of balance out to some
degree so I think the one out of every
14 or 15 people is certainly a pretty
rough estimate but if if you like if
there was a population study retook like
a million people and had them train hard
for five years if the number of people
who wound up with a fad or the number of
men at least who wound up with a fat
free mass index over twenty five if it
was less than one percent I'd be pretty
surprised and if it was more than ten
percent I'd be pretty surprised
like any number between like one and 10%
like within that order of magnitude
would make I it would match my
observations it would also match like
the current estimate we can get from the
research and that's one of those numbers
were like for any given individual it is
less likely than it is likely but it's
also not something where you have to be
some sort of absurd genetic outlier to
get there right I mean you're talking
about millions of people walking around
in the United States that have that
potential correct yeah so you know just
to kind of wrap things up I certainly
would never suggest that it's like a
super common thing like oh yeah most
people can get to 25 shredded but I
don't think it's quite as rare as people
make it out to because a lot of people
make it out to be like a hard
physiological boundary that cannot be
circumvented and I don't think the data
support that and I also very much
questioned the utility of even defining
a limit like that because it's like one
of those things people like say hey am i
near my genetic limit in most cases
they're not actually gonna do anything
with that information they're gonna feel
something based on your answer but like
it's always just like dude we'll just
keep trying and you know keep training
hard and like we talked to Mike to shear
the other day yeah a couple months ago
and he was like well he's been a
world-class strength athlete since I was
in high school and I think the phrase he
used was I'm gonna keep turning over
more rocks right and until until there
are no more rocks to turn over there are
some gains out there theoretically to be
had and he's gonna seek him yeah I mean
when someone asks me that question of
like do you think I'm close to my limits
my answer is always just like that train
for another five years and let me know
yeah that's how you answer that question
and that is the only way I am aware of
that
you can answer that question yeah yeah
so again I I don't think it's a super
common thing I wouldn't say oh
definitely most people can get there but
if someone tells me hey I got 225 and
I'm pretty shredded do you think we
should do some kind of
a study to figure out how this could
possibly be happening I'd be like no
like that makes sense that should be a
thing that happens sometimes so like the
idea that you're gonna use it as like a
hard cutoff and make it the final
determinant of the natty or not
discussion III just don't buy into it
man
so whenever this comes up the thing that
always comes to mind immediately is and
so like I don't know if he still
believes this or not but back in the day
Gregorio Gallagher made a video where he
wouldn't got a DEXA scan and his fat
free mass index came out at like I think
it was like twenty four point six I
think it was just like feast your eyes
guys this is as big as a person can get
and I mean like you know dudes jacked
like he has a good physique but just
like the I don't know I I could never
conceive of myself in any context
getting on camera and doing that be like
yeah maybe have another half a kilo that
I could put on somewhere but you know
that this is the peak humans can't get
bigger than this without drugs
especially because like he doesn't even
train legs hard right I don't know I
have no idea I think that's a thing
where he's like yeah you don't want to
get big legs they're unaesthetic just
like do plyos and jumping and stuff so I
mean even just based on that unless he
thinks that plyos maximize lower body
hypertrophy that's kind of a it's kind
of a weird claim to make and also just
like again I I was watching that video
and putting myself in that position yeah
I just could never see myself ever
saying that yeah I I will say this the
people who believe in 25 is being this
hard cap there's an inverse association
with how much time they've spent with
really elite athletes who do strong
person stuff football lifters just
really high level athletes in those
endeavors because man I've been around
some like NFL Combine training stuff and
just talk to some of the athletes
they literally have some of them have
never put one moment of thought into
what they eat at all they eat when
they're hungry and they eat the stuff
they've always ate because it tastes
good and they they look like just the
absolute peak human physique and you're
like dude you could easily add so much
to that physique if you even thought
about it and so like there's something
to be said about hanging out with freaks
and it will really change your mind
about what is potentially possible for a
human no I I agree wholeheartedly okay
let's let's move on to the next question
here this one is also by Grant is that a
mistake we made or is that for real
a lot of grants out there maybe it might
be a different grant I'm not sure I
think there are more than one but in any
case grant asks what are your thoughts
on touch and go deadlifts compared to
resetting between reps for general
jimbros who are just trying to get
jacked personally I can do several more
reps close to double when doing touch
and go but I've read that you are better
off to let the weight settle between
reps what do you think Gregg so that's a
good question I am personally of the
opinion that bouncing probably isn't a
great idea but that touch and go is just
fine and possibly even advisable reason
why I would advocate against bouncing is
one first and foremost like there's
gonna be a fair amount of shock when the
weight hits the ground you know not
trying to catastrophize anything or
nocebo anyone out there but you know if
you are going to have an acute injury
generally big spikes or big changes in
forces over a very short period of time
is a is a reasonably decent way to go
about accomplishing that
so yeah bouncing not a huge fan I mean
there are times to bounce if you're a
strongman competitor and you're doing
axial deadlifts and they have bumpers on
the bar or there's like a relatively
spongy platform that you can get a
bounce off of like dude it's like it's
your sport you're gonna score points for
getting more reps
you can get more reps bouncing like do
it but you know this guy's asking with
the assumption that you're just a normal
gym bro and you're just trying to get
big in that context I would recommend
against bouncing but if you're doing
touch-and-go assuming that it's just
like a soft touch or you know you're not
just like slamming the weights down and
calling it touch-and-go but really it's
like slam and then immediately reverse
it I think that's perfectly fine I think
one there's probably not going to be any
meaningful increase in in risk of acute
injury again as long as the the touch is
relatively soft which unless you're in
specifically a strength sports gym it
will probably need to be because people
will come over and chew you out if
you're too loud about your touch and go
deadlifts so I think that it's not
necessarily going to increase risk I
think it is going to give you the added
benefit of forcing you to do a real
eccentric so the if you look at the
research on like eccentric only training
compared to concentric only training
compared to like combined eccentric and
concentric people used to think back in
the day that like the the majority of
the strength gains you got were just
from the concern just from the eccentric
so like you know maybe by doing full
reps you're actually limiting your
hypertrophy because you can handle more
load eccentric ly than you can
concentrically so if you're you know
doing like normal isotonic reps you're
actually limiting the eccentric loading
you're doing and leaving growth on the
table that doesn't seem to be the case
it doesn't seem like you need to
necessarily maximize eccentric loading
to maximize hypertrophy but you are
probably missing out on some growth if
you are mostly assuming the eccentric
like you don't grow as much from
concentric only training as you do
eccentric or combined training and so a
lot of times when people are resetting
deadlift reps
they're either they're either dropping
the bar or like
not dropping it they're keeping their
hands on it but they're really not
resisting it as it goes back to the
ground and then they reset and pull
another rep if you're doing touch-and-go
if you are going to touch and go you
need to be in control of the bar when
it's at the ground so I think that I
think that in terms of like general
training adaptations if you're doing
touch and go deadlifts or if you're
resetting between reps and your you're
actually doing eccentric either way like
if you're resetting but you are still
controlling the bar to the ground
sending it down softly resetting pulling
again I think that and touch-and-go will
probably give you pretty similar
training effects and I think if I was
going to give a benefit to one or the
other it would probably be touch and go
just because it forces you to do that
we're like you can't get lazy towards
the end of a set and start kind of
skimping on the eccentric so that's
that's my personal feeling on the on the
topic bouncing isn't good resetting is
good as long as you're actually doing
the eccentric and touch-and-go I think
is I think it's good I mean so it's
weird people treat the deadlift as if
it's some sort of like just weird thing
and completely different than every
other exercise compared to something
like a bench or a squat where you know I
guess with a bench there's a clear
bottom because you're touching the
weight on your chest both squat you just
go down stop come back up if you're
doing a touch-and-go deadlift it's
essentially the same thing
except it's kind of like it's kind of
like a box squat that you might see in
an athletic training type facility where
they have like a soft pad on the box and
they have people squat down until they
can like feel the pad on their butt and
then come back up but not like fully sit
on it if you're doing a soft touch and
go deadlifts that's essentially the same
thing but yeah so I mean if you're a
power lifter I think you should
definitely practice resetting enough and
pulling enough like first reps that you
know actually Maxine at
left on the platform isn't going to be a
big surprise but for just like a normal
gym bro
like I think touch and go is just fine
and possibly even preferable yeah so I
you know the last like five or six years
I did a lot of work with a Special
Olympics powerlifting team and you know
we have to be really attentive to
technique and making sure that we're
gonna be able to translate exactly the
way we're training onto the platform and
minimize as many variables as we can
which is true for essentially any type
of powerlifting really but you know what
I would always do is whenever I have a
lifter who their first repetition on the
deadlift was always their tough one
and it just the the technique technique
was a little sloppy but once they got in
the groove of their touch and goes it
would really clean up rep after rep
with those guys I'd say hey we're
resetting every single rep because we
need to fit we need to figure out that
technical deficit on that first rep off
the ground so I I think that's one
additional cat I agree with everything
you said that one additional caveat is
if you are a touch and go deadlifts
and you lift just kind of sucks but then
once you get into the flow of the touch
and goes it really cleans itself up or
you just have a better groove with the
touch and go reps I think that might be
something to focus on if that's the case
as well something that may be worth
doing is comparing your technique on
your first rep versus your touch-and-go
reps mm-hmm often times what you see is
that once you once you get the the touch
and go going is that you hinge more and
squat less so in general I think I don't
think it's a bad idea to try to set up
with like tine of lowish hips and then
just you know the bar won't break the
ground until your hips rise high enough
to where they need to be but I think for
for people who do characteristically do
well with touch-and-go but really
struggle to get that first rep off the
ground it may be worth experimenting
with a higher hip position for for your
first rep because that will be getting
you more into the position that you
would be getting into for touch-and-go
more
often than not definitely all right
looks like we are getting into the
nutrition side of things with this next
question from Chris yeah so Chris asks
you guys have talked about diet breaks
before while cutting do you think it
would be beneficial to do the same for
bulking for example bulk for three weeks
maintenance for one so the only
theoretical benefit I could see here is
if you just really hate eating and
you're just like I need a break from
this I could see there being some kind
of subjective psychological benefit
potentially but in terms of the
physiology behind it I would say you
probably don't want to take diet breaks
on a bulk the reason being is the
physiological responses to bulking and
cutting are mechanistically distinct so
when we talk about these diet breaks
when it comes to weight loss diets or
while cutting there's kind of a specific
cause and this is a very targeted
solution to that cause so you know
whenever we start a cut we we typically
see that leptin begins to drop and we
feel that drop in leptin and it starts
to induce both short and long term
changes that are pretty pronounced so we
can identify this leptin drop it's
sensitive to both short term and long
term energy stores and leptin really is
if you are gonna take all the aspects of
metabolic adaptation and the related
kind of side effects related to it you
could really pin the vast majority of
that on leptin and so what we'll see is
if we have people doing like a big
weight loss diet and they have all the
key signs of metabolic adaptation if we
literally just do a leptin infusion we
solve most of those problems almost
instantly so a lot of the the idea
behind these these diet breaks while
cutting is to attenuate some of those
metabolic adaptations that are resulting
from from low leptin levels and so you
can argue exactly how strong the
evidence is for that there are some good
examples of studies in which various
diet break interventions have been
somewhat helpful in trying to attenuate
aspects of metabolic adaptation
it's by no means a cure it's it's not
like you know a complete game-changer
for dieting but I do think it's one of
the few solutions that actually make
sense to try to implement while while
doing a diet and you know we're gonna
see a lot more diet break research
coming coming out in the coming years
we'll see if it continues to pan out
like some of the early promising stuff
as indicated but even if there's not a
physiological benefit there should at
least especially when dieting everybody
could use a week off of their weight
loss diet from time to time so even if
that leptin physiology isn't really
coming through and making meaningful
changes at the very least I could see
big-time application of the
psychological or subjective benefits but
theoretically when we're dieting we're
on a weight-loss diet you know cutting
weight whatever you want to call it
we have those drops in leptin eating at
energy maintenance you know in energy
balance for a short period of time might
give us a transient increase in leptin
levels which might help to attenuate
some of those adaptations we associate
with the drops in leptin now if we look
at the reverse situation if we look at
well what about a diet break while
bulking now definitely there is a
physiological response to over feeding
it tends to vary widely between people
but there are some people that are
pretty resistant to weight gain and in
really well controlled interventions
where we over feed them in experimental
conditions what we'll find is that they
have adaptations to that over feeding
where they basically match their
expenditure to that caloric surplus and
are very very resistant to actually
storing additional weight in response to
that over feeding some people have a
much less pronounced response to over
feeding you over feed them they store
the energy quite readily and they gain
weight so the problem is it's not as
easy to do any kind of intervention
targeting leptin that's going to really
deal with that and so what I'm getting
at is with dieting the leptin the leptin
stuff is pretty straightforward when
you're dieting due to the acute energy
deficit and the loss of fat mass we see
leptin go down
if we replace that leptin it works and
the best way to do that is just by
injecting it but that's not a very
practical solution now if you're at your
normal body weight and we start over
feeding you
leptin will go up as you start to gain
weight but the problem is we can
essentially become resistant to that
leptin so when we first started seeing
this stuff with leptin and seeing how
potent it was to do leptin replacement a
lot of people thought oh hell yeah we
solved obesity take an obese person
inject them full leptin and they're
gonna lose weight like crazy in reality
that failed what happens is somebody's
at a normal body weight they've got
plenty of leptin you give them more they
just become more resistant to that
signal so the idea that you would do
these diet breaks to do anything related
to leptin while bulking I really don't
think there's much there based on the
physiological rationale theoretically
you could give yourself a little break
from bulking if you're just absolutely
sick of eating but rather than do that I
think I'm probably you're your first
approach before you resort to something
like that would be well how do we just
make this bulking diet a little bit more
feasible and enjoyable and so I would
say look at your diet figure out if
there are any changes you can make that
enhance or I guess increase your energy
intake without making you feel really
full and bloated and gross because when
people are really hating their bulking
diets it's usually bad they're just like
I feel sick all the time I'm bloated I
have no appetite whatsoever and so in
those cases you start looking at things
like what is the physical like volume of
your diet are there ways that you can
eat less physical amounts of food while
having the same energy intake you know
what's your fiber intake like could you
maybe even tweak your protein intake to
allow for you know maybe you have more
than enough protein you drop your
protein a little bit to get some more
carbs in there so just looking at what
is the overall energy density of this
diet and how can I make some
substitutions so that I still am eating
enough calories but it's just not as
filling and it doesn't make me feel as
bloated so the key things I usually look
for there are do we have way more
protein than we need
do we have more fiber than we need how
do we make some of those substitutions
so I would say that would be the best
option because you know if you're
bulking you want to be in a caloric
surplus and any breaks you take away
from that are just essentially extending
the timeline of your bulk but they're
not actually doing anything
physiologically that I can think of that
is dealing with any sort of adaptive
process so the really short answer is I
I think the best the best approach there
if you're bulking and you hate it and
you feel full all the time take a look
at your food options try to see if you
make can make some swaps to increase the
energy density of what you're eating
okay now we've got a question from
Jillian okay so do you have any
evidence-based suggestions for a female
who is looking to maintain muscle mass
and gain strength but without inducing
further hypertrophy yeah so if that's a
good question and it's the answer to the
question is essentially do all of the
opposites of what one would recommend if
you were trying to maximize hypertrophy
with the caveat that you're still
training so one of the first things one
might do if they're trying to get big is
potentially increased training volume if
you're you know if you're recovering
well from the current amount of volume
you're doing but you're not making gains
at the rate you would like higher
volumes to a point seem to enhance
muscle hypertrophy so one of the things
you can do if you're trying to keep
getting stronger but minimizing
hypertrophy is you can cut back on
volume and there is I think pretty
strong evidentiary rationale for that so
there were a couple meta analyses
published in the last year to 18 months
or so looking at the effects of training
volume so weekly sets on both
hypertrophy and strength the hypertrophy
medow was from Schoenfeld and colleagues
and the strength medow was from Ralston
and colleagues and they were pretty much
set up the same way so they would
category
set volume as low moderate or high with
low-beam fewer than five sets per muscle
group per week moderate being five to
nine and high being ten plus and both of
them found that higher volumes tended to
lead to more hypertrophy and strength
but the difference between low volume so
below five sets per week and high volume
so 10 plus sets per week in the
hypertrophy meta-analysis was it was
essentially a two-fold difference in
growth but in the strength meta-analysis
it was only like a 20% difference give
or take so you know you will make more
strength gains by using higher volume to
a point but it's not going to be quite
as large of a difference as it would be
for hypertrophy like you're going to be
leaving some rate of strength progress
on the table but not a tremendous amount
at least in the short to moderate term
so that is one thing you could do just
cut back on the amount of volume that
you're doing and interestingly there was
also another meta-analysis by I'm not
gonna attempt to pronounce his name he's
a Greek he goes by pact PA K and his
instagram handle is polka rots
he's currently doing his PhD over in
england and he did a meta-analysis just
to look and see like in trained
populations - not untrained lifters with
people who have at least some degree of
training experience what seems to be the
least training they can get away with
and still make progress in the power
lifts so he was interested in squat
bench and deadlift but was only able to
find studies looking at bench and squat
and in that meta-analysis he basically
found that as long as you're doing one
set to failure or near failure two to
three times per lift per week at
somewhere in the neighborhood of like 70
to 85 or 90% 1rm you'll probably be able
to keep making strength gains at least
in the short to moderate term it's worth
noting that all of the studies included
in that
analysis were using male lifters and
Jillian was asking about females I'm not
aware of a good a priori reason to
assume that that wouldn't apply to
females as well but it's at least worth
noting and it's also worth noting that
the subjects in those studies did have
some degree of prior training experience
but weren't like super-strong inject so
the the average the average like
pre-training benchpress was probably
close to 100 kilos squat about 140 150
so you know people who had some training
experience but we're like kind of late
beginner to early intermediate lifters
but you know one set two to three times
per week seemed to be sufficient so yeah
you can cut back on volume pretty
substantially and at least in the short
term still be able to make strength
progress if not much or any hypertrophy
progress other things you can try is if
you don't want to do a set to failure
close to failure at 70 to 85 percent 1rm
you could just do quite heavy work for
low reps you know you're probably not
gonna grow much from doing say five
singles and 90% 1rm so you know if you
wanted to do for those two sessions per
week if you wanted to do one of them
where you just take you know 75 80
percent of your max and do a set to
failure and for the other one you throw
90 percent on the bar and do some
singles that would probably be a good
way to make some strength progress while
not growing much if any another thing
you can do is just make sure you always
train quite far from failure so we've
talked about we've talked about the
concept of effective reps on this
podcast before and just generally do you
need to train to failure very close to
failure to maximize hypertrophy and kind
of my takeaway from all of that is that
like you have to be kind of close to
failure but you don't need to go all the
way there to maximize hypertrophy on a
per set basis but
if you stay quite far from failure you
will probably at least be able to limit
hypertrophy to some degree and there
have been three studies now
testing testing strength gains after
various degrees of velocity loss so that
would equate to training different
training at different proximities from
failure so the earliest study was
testing the 20% versus 40% velocity loss
per set and there were two more that
came out this month testing a 50% versus
a 25% velocity loss per set and then
another one testing just a 5% versus a
25% velocity loss per set and in all
three of those studies the the group
that trained with a smaller velocity
loss per set so training further from
failure gained just as much strength as
the group training with a larger
velocity loss per set and thus closer to
failure so you can probably you know if
you look at your training program now
and say you're doing five sets of five
at 80% first one maybe you have three
reps in reserve and last one maybe you
just have one rep in reserve you're
pretty close to failure at least in the
short-term you can probably make some
strength gains by still doing five sets
at 80% and instead of doing sets of five
just doing doubles or triples again
probably not going to grow from that
it's probably going to be quite far from
failure probably a little bit further
from failure than is optimal to maximize
hypertrophy certainly and we'll probably
still promote some hypertrophy but not a
ton but at least in the short to
moderate term you should be able to make
strength gains off of it and then
another one which you know this is like
if you loved your current training
program and don't want to change a thing
about it
you could just take an ice bath after
training which you know maybe you hate
ice baths which if so cool you're the
same as like 98% of people but there's
pretty consistent research at this point
like four or five studies showing that
taking like a 15 minute ice bath after
train
severely limits hypertrophy on training
programs that are pretty strongly
hypertrophic so if you just don't want
to think about programming and you like
your current program but you're just
growing too much on it more than you
would prefer you're gonna stop in the
ice bath deal with the cold and limit
some of the growth you get from it so
those are all strategies you can use and
one of the things I've said probably
thirty times as I've been answering this
question is these are things you can do
to keep making strength gains in the
short to moderate term the reason I
always couch it in in the short to
moderate term is that eventually you're
going to be limited by the amount of
muscle mass you have so one of the
things we see looking at various lines
of research is that there is a lot of
room certainly fairly early in the
training process but also even as people
get more well trained for their strength
and performance in more complex
exercises to improve as their motor
skill improves and as their technique
improves so you know if you currently
squat 400 pounds and you want to squat
for 50 you very well may be able to get
from 400 to 450 without putting more
muscle on but when we strip away the
skill and technique and just boil it
down to the sheer ability of a muscle to
contract and produce force what we see
is there is a incredibly strong
relationship between muscle
cross-sectional area and its ability to
produce force in an isometric context
and you know ISO metrics are great so
just like an isometric knee extension
because like it takes no skill
whatsoever you just sit there you kick
as hard as he can you don't need to
worry about movement efficiency you're
just kicking into something that can't
move and we see that even in untrained
folks their ability to
produce force is at 90-95 percent plus
of their theoretical maximum so like you
know if you have someone kick into a
immovable pad and see how many Newton
meters of torque they're producing and
then you deliver a shock to their motor
nerve to force the muscle to contract as
hard as possible it's only gonna add
like another two three percent to that
amount of force so like that gives us a
pretty good estimate of just sheer ly
how much force a muscle can produce and
that scales so strongly with muscle
cross-sectional area that it's
absolutely insane there was a recent
study that came out that I just reviewed
in mass o that I'm going to review and
mass it comes out February 1st spoilers
spoilers yeah where they were basically
looking to see like why do more trained
people produce more force than less
trained people and there were a couple
little things that made like a small
difference here and there so like
normalized muscle force was a little bit
higher the quadriceps moment arms like
the patellar tendon moment arm was a
little bit longer but essentially like
the largest explanatory factor was just
that the trained people had way larger
quads than the untrained people and you
could in like there's a like when they
ran a regression like the untrained
people in the train people fell on the
same trendline like the relationship
between muscle mass and strength was was
the same for the entire cohort for all
intents and purposes and also you can
see that when you look at high load
versus low low training research so you
know if you have two groups and one of
them is doing squats at 80 percent what
RM and the other ones doing squats at 50
percent one RM they're going to get
similar hypertrophy the group squatting
at 80 percent one RM is going to have a
larger increase in squat one RM but then
if you put them on a isokinetic
dynamometer set in an isometric mode
have them kick out against it their
gains in isometric strength are pretty
similar in addition to their increases
in muscle size so yeah like just the
sheer capacity to produce force that's
dependent on how big your muscles are
so all of those strategies I gave before
are ways that you can go about
continuing to train continuing to get
reps in continuing to get practice where
you can hone your motor skills hone your
technique and keep making some strength
gains with the amount of muscle you
currently have but ultimately there's
gonna be a cap on how strong you can get
unless you add more muscle to your frame
so everything I just said is going to
apply to strength gains in the short to
moderate term in the long term you
either need to decide like okay there's
a max of how strong I can get with the
amount of muscle I have and I just have
to be happy with that or if you're
trying to maximize strength gains you
will eventually need to get bigger at
some point that makes sense
all right so one last question here this
one is from Dylan it looks like yeah so
Dylan asks I lift in the morning and I
don't like to eat breakfast that early
usually I have a shake with two scoops
of whey and about 10 grams of dextrose
30 to 45 minutes before lifting is that
enough pre-workout nutrition for an
optimal workout would there be any
benefit to a post-workout shake as well
or is the pre-workout protein sufficient
yeah this is a topic that comes up a lot
you know I coach clients a lot of them
do train early in the morning because
they're like hey I've got a job I got
the family I just got to get into the
gym and kind of get it out of the way
before I start my day and the last thing
anybody wants to hear is like oh you're
working out at 5:00 why don't you wake
up at 3:00 you know have a nice big
balanced breakfast let that digest and
then two hours later you should be ready
to go so when it comes to pre-workout
nutrition it's tough a lot of times
there's a restricted time window if
you're you know you're busy you got work
and all that stuff and we really have to
focus in on a few factors we need it to
be digestible so it's not going to cause
any stomach discomfort or nausea while
training we want to make sure that we
have some amount of amino acids in the
blood in that post work like immediate
post-workout period and a lot of times
people think oh then I'll just have a
shake immediately but there's still some
time but before those amino acids you
drink after the workout are actually
present in the bloodstream and doing
their thing in terms of supporting
muscle protein synthesis
we want to make sure that we are
optimizing carbohydrate availability to
the extent that our macros allow so you
know if you're walking into walking into
a workout with really low muscle and
liver glycogen stores and you're 12
hours fasted or eight hours fasted
that's probably not you're probably
going to be struggling late in that
workout if you're doing a lot of
glycolytic activity and even though you
know traditional resistance training
isn't super glycolytic you're still
probably gonna feel that on the
performance end and another thing that I
don't hear people talk about a lot but I
think it's critically important is just
avoiding hunger during the workout like
I tend to get hungry during workouts a
lot because I suck at training on a full
stomach
so if I'm ever gonna miss with my
pre-workout nutrition I'm going to under
eat not overeat and what I'll find is
sometimes toward the end of a longer
workout I start getting hungry and
that's just not a place you want to be
like just subjectively that is just a
horrible workout it sucks trying to lift
when you're like really really hungry so
we don't want any of that stuff to
happen so looking at what Dillon here
has presented two scoops away 10 grams
of dextrose 30 to 45 minutes before if I
was starting from scratch I would
probably say the scoops of whey that
that could be kind of it depends so like
I've seen whey products that each scoop
has like 17 grams of whey protein and
two scoops would put you like usually I
tell people you know 20 to 40 grams of
protein before the workout whatever you
can handle in terms of digestibility
sometimes people are really sensitive to
that and so you might look at either a
hydrolyzed whey product or if even that
isn't working then you look for like an
isolated product of essential amino
acids but in any case yeah I like to
give like a good or recommend a 20 to 40
gram dose of protein depending on your
body size depending on how well you can
tolerate it if your stomach can't handle
it then just an equivalent dose of just
a just the essential amino acids that it
would provide otherwise so that's where
I start with the protein with the
carbohydrate you know it does depend on
both body size and the amount of
glycolytic activity or
doing your overall training volume and
it also depends on what your macros are
for the day you know sometimes we have
all the calories in the world to play
with sometimes one really restricted
carbs but generally I like to say if we
can get away with a good 20 to 60 grams
of carbs before the workout 60 being
definitely on the high end but at least
I like to get a good 20 grams of carbs
in just to make sure that we have some
degree of carbohydrate availability as
we're walking in the gym the gym door
and able to support whatever glycolytic
activity we might be doing so with
pre-workout you know fat I don't worry
about and if you do have issues with
digestion or nausea you might want to
look at your pre-workout meal and see if
you have a ton of fiber or a ton of fat
in it that might be slowing digestion
particularly a high-fat pre-workout diet
can really induce nausea and a lot of
people that are training pretty hard but
I like to get like I said about you know
20 to 40 grams of protein or an
equivalent dose of essential amino acids
not 20 to 40 grams but the amount of
essential amino acids you would have
gotten from that 20 to 40 gram of what
20 to 40 grams of protein and then on
the carb side you know 20 to 60 ish
depending on on what you can get away
with and depending on your body size
with the idea of the post-workout shake
I don't think you know people have gone
back and forth about this anabolic
window thing it's not quite as narrow a
window as once thought I would say if
you do have that sufficient protein dose
before the workout that 20 to 40 grams
it definitely gives you a lot more of a
cushion in terms of how rapidly you need
to get your post-workout meal in but I
would definitely say within an hour or
two of training you'll want to get that
post-workout protein dose for most
people and it's one of those things
where you could theoretically see
downsides to prolonging that window or
missing that meal but it's it's hard to
see what benefit you would get from
intentionally delaying that post-workout
protein feeding so you know getting that
protein soon after the workout within an
hour or two has some potential to be
beneficial
has really no potential to do harm and
aside from maybe just some inconvenience
but it should be easy enough to find
some kind of protein containing product
whether it's a shake a bar or a
traditional meal that you can get within
that 1 to 2 hour period after so that's
pretty much where I start with
pre-workout nutrition and if we run into
issues with you know stomach issues
hunger kind of hitting the wall late in
the workout then we troubleshoot from
there and tweak those parameters as
needed makes sense to me all right now
moving on we've got a research roundup
segment we're about an hour and a half
in so we're gonna have to be concise and
just give very hot takes with as few
words as possible I'm gonna be on the
flip side after our last episode which
was like two and a half hours I had no
less than three people messaged me
disappointed that it was a regular like
non Q&A episode that was under three
hours with two of them suggesting that
now that we're recording half is often a
four would be the ideal our number four
episodes they weren't serious though I
think at least one of them was quite
serious oh no that that's well I guess I
okay we'll go for them here we go for
four so this one it's a research roundup
because it's a recent paper that I found
kind of looking through the journal
sweep but I also noticed that it does
kind of answer a listeners question so
if you're a loyal listener and I know
you are you remember a few episodes back
I forget when we were talking a little
bit about high protein diets and whether
or not they were potentially harmful or
deleterious in terms of health effects
walk through some of the stuff when it
comes to liver and kidney health and I
planted the seed I mentioned the acid
ash hypothesis related to bone health
and I don't think I sufficiently kind of
closed off that thought like I don't
think I really wrapped it up in my
discussion so Boris had a question he's
like hey you talked a little bit about
protein and bone and this acid ash
hypothesis but you never really tied it
together
and there was actually a paper I think a
couple weeks ago or something that that
really applies quite well to his
questions so we're talking about
high-protein diets here and we're
talking about their effects on bone
health the acid ash hypothesis basically
suggests that if you're eating a
high-protein diet it's gonna have a high
dietary acid load and what's gonna
happen is the body is gonna try to you
know in response to that chronic low
level acidosis it's gonna start leaching
some of the minerals from bone mass to
try to help buffer that acidity and in
the process you're going to lose bone
mass and bone density ultimately leading
to poorer bone health osteoporosis
etc and so there is some grain of truth
to that that the body does have the
capacity to do that but you know what I
believe I mentioned it last time it
doesn't really pan out when we look at
the data when it comes to high protein
diets and bone health historically
speaking the studies have indicated in
Decatur that high-protein diets have
either had a neutral to a slightly
positive effect on long-term outcomes
related to bone health now there is a
recent meta-analysis by Wright and
colleagues like I said I think it was
just a few weeks ago but it was called
effects of dietary protein quantity on
bone quantity following weight loss a
systematic review and meta-analysis and
so what they found you know was a
systematic review they got all the
studies that were relevant to the
question kind of combined all the
results mathematically and the the very
brief summary of those results were that
during weight loss it was generally
found that there was some loss of bone
density in response to that weight loss
but the loss of both total bone mineral
density and lumbar spine bone mineral
density
both of those were attenuated by a
high-protein diet in comparison to a low
protein diet
and the way that they categorized those
diets they said it's a high-protein diet
if at least 25% of the calories were
coming from protein or if it provided at
least one gram per kilogram of body mass
and list
are probably thinking that's not high
protein but in the clinical nutrition
literature it kind of is
you know usually 0.8 grams per kilogram
is what they would call like a
completely sufficient intake of protein
which most lifters are absolutely just
enraged by the concept but in any case
the the the clinical significance of the
finding was kind of debatable just
because the overall size of the effect
wasn't that notable like it wasn't like
an amount of difference in bone mineral
density that you would you would look at
it and say wow these are two people in
completely different health situations
because of this difference in bone mass
however it is important to note that
most of these studies are pretty short
term and the longer studies that work
that lasted at least three months the
the difference between the groups was
more notable so the stuff that was like
less than three months bones don't
really morphologically change that
rapidly and so you have to give these
studies enough time to really get a
solid bone response in terms of density
and bone mineral content but the longer
ones were were more likely to find a
little bit of a separation between the
high protein and low protein groups
again these studies would not indicate
that the magnitudes they observed were
like completely groundbreaking like
game-changers for your health however at
the very least should give us plenty of
confidence to say when I do select a
high protein diet because I like its
effects on weight management fat mass
lean mass performance I'm not making a
trade-off in which I'm sacrificing my
bone health in fact the opposite tends
to be true where we see modest positive
effects on bone health
okay now that is the research roundup
part that I feel really good about this
next study before we get into it this is
just speculation all over the place this
is way outside my area that I feel like
really really comfortable in but I just
thought it was fascinating so it's kind
of like when we talked about that study
with lactate and epigenetics and we were
like hey here's a cool thing I'm not
really ready to make like really hot
takes about exactly what it means but
seems interesting that's pretty much
where I'm at with this one and
I'll defer to your opinion on what some
of the ramifications might be if you
have any but in any case I thought this
was really cool because it was a huge
case of confirmation bias for me and as
long as you proclaim that on the front
end I think you're safe this is just
massive confirmation bias for me so when
I say confirmation bias late in contest
prep anyone who's done the whole
bodybuilding thing knows you're depleted
you're flat
you have no glycogen but also during a
workout you will never catch a pump and
people say oh it's the sodium it's the
carbs it's just the general energy
deficit it's probably all of it but
basically you start lifting and that
whole idea that you start lifting the
muscle starts filling up with some fluid
it kind of gets larger acutely and you
can sense that you know the whole Arnold
Schwarzenegger pump thing it just
doesn't happen when you're pretty late
in contest prep and you're still in that
deficit but what you also find is like
there are some days where you're just
like it's not just that I'm
underperforming with the weights it's
like I am weirdly weak like something is
happening here because I am weak as hell
and so this study just kind of I wonder
if there's something to it so the title
of the study with all of that
introductory material there that the
title of study is passive muscle tension
increases in proportion to intramuscular
fluid volume and this is by Sloboda
and colleagues published just within the
last month or so so during exercise
water does diffuse into muscle and you
know we can see that muscle fluid volume
increases you can feel it with the pump
and estimates indicate that the fluid
content of a muscle can increase
anywhere from 1 to 20 percent during
exercise and what they are trying to
look at in this study using some some
interesting models is does that have a
fat in effect on the passive tension
provided by a muscle while it's being
stretched and so what they did was they
use two different models here one was an
isolated bullfrog muscle they used the
semimembranosus muscle
and in order to change the the fluid
volume of the muscle they would just
soak the muscle in different solutions
with various tonicity so like if you
were remember back to your chemistry
class when they would talk about
hypertonic hypotonic solutions they use
these different solutions to kind of
encourage the muscle to take up more or
less fluid and alter the fluid volume
that way the other model they used was
like this sleeve of flexible plastic
fibers that was supposed to represent a
collagenous extracellular matrix of the
muscle and now Greg let's say you've got
a sleeve of flexible plastic fibers but
within that you need something to
represent like a water-filled the
bladder so to speak what are you gonna
use as a researcher that's a good
question
IIIi would need to think about it but
given the shape of muscles I think who
among us has not looked at really any
muscle and thought man that looks like a
penis correct yeah that's pretty much
how I feel about most muscles and so
what they did with with this study is
they used this within that plastic fiber
structure they put in a Trojan Enz
non-lubricated phallic latex tube device
also known as a condom and they filled
it with different amounts of fluid to
kind of alter the fluid volume of this
physical model now what they found
basically they got their findings from
the isolated bullfrog muscle and then
they essentially replicated it with a
physical model nay they seem to line up
pretty well but but what their results
indicated was there was a correlation
between the fluid volume and the passive
muscle tension that they observed and
and that was correlated over a 20%
increase in fluid volume compared to the
baseline volume and what they found was
that even a 5% volume increase based on
their models resulted in a passive force
increase of even a little over 10%
and so at face value these findings
would suggest that physio
irrelevant changes in muscle fluid
volume could alter some of the passive
muscle mechanics and the overall just
just the amount of extra oomph you get
from some of that passive tension in the
muscle while lifting because this is so
far out of my area of expertise I don't
want to like over interpret the results
that much but I still found it to be
very fascinating and you can think of
the some of the potential applications
you know like I said it reminded me of
contest prep when you're just like
remarkably weak you will never ever get
a pump and you know you think okay well
I haven't lost a lot of muscle but maybe
this is just kind of a bioenergetic
issue I don't have the glycogen to
support you know the lifting activity
I'm trying to do but it really feels
like there's more than that going on and
so this is just feeding into my
confirmation bias that maybe it's the
bioenergetic ramifications of low
glycogen coupled with maybe you're not
getting as much passive tension out of
the muscle as you were hoping I again
this is not my area of expertise it
looks like you're about to disagree with
me so I mean here's here's a question
for you yeah so most power lifters
aren't ever going to cut as aggressively
as a bodybuilder well in prep but one of
the things that that I'd noticed and
that a lot of my clients have reported
back to me is that when you go on a cut
squats are okay like they may drop and
strength a little bit deadlift is
usually fine and you know if you're
cutting from like heavy weight to
smaller deadlift may even improve as
you're like set up gets better but that
bench just drops off a cliff have you
noticed that the same is true like do
you find that like upper-body stuff is
just really messed up whereas like lower
body is a little bit more maintainable
or is it just kind of both fall off a
cliff no so when it comes to a normal
cut of going from like I was kind of you
know fatter than I normally would be to
like a normal body comp I do notice that
it's lift specific it seems to be more
of a
kind of mechanical kind of thing but
when it gets to that like late stage
prep it's everything it's even the
simplest of exercises a bicep curl to me
feels like it's the heaviest thing in
the world
maybe I'm weird I don't know like I said
I don't want to I don't want to give the
impression that I'm like overextending
these results and saying like oh this is
definitely super applicable to humans in
vivo and this is definitely what I
noticed during prep but it was one of
those things where because I was looking
for it I was like oh this totally
explains it so I don't want to over over
extend the results or have excessive
confidence in it but at the very least I
thought it was a cool paper and and if
it does turn out to pan out to being
meaningful in vivo for humans then the
applications would be cool when it comes
to managing your hydration status your
glycogen status and even ozma lytic
supplements like like creatine betaine
things that increase fluid volume within
the muscle so my take on it is that it
is probably still more due to glycogen
and like regional glycogen depletion mmm
this is something we've talked about on
the podcast before but essentially the
[Music]
the like parts of the if you get
glycogen depletion around the the
myofibrils and then also around the
machinery that that handles like calcium
release and reabsorption that seems to
really pretty substantially decrease
one's ability to produce force and so
kind of my thinking here and I don't
know if this is true or not but my
thinking here was that like when you go
into an acute deficit you get some
glycogen depletion you'll probably get
some regional depletion of glycogen
specifically around those parts of the
fiber first because like they're the
most active in day to day life and so
when glycogen levels start getting low
that's probably those are probably the
the glycogen Depot's that are gonna go
first and then like I don't know if this
makes sense or not but I would think
just in general that maybe upper
glycogen would deplete before lower body
glycogen would just maybe from an
evolutionary perspective because you
know you're hungry you're starving on
the Savannah you need to hunt down
something to eat let's make sure you
have energy in your legs more so than
your arms to walk around and try to
scavenge some stuff I don't know but
then yeah maybe like deep and prep like
everything starving you have no clike
again and then upper body and then lower
body stuff falls off a cliff too so like
that was kind of my thinking and to
counter that study that you don't have
the expertise to comment intelligently
on I'm going to present a study which I
also don't have the expertise to to come
it intelligently on this is what the
listeners came here yeah this is now at
this point this is a Facebook comment
section so there was a another study
which so I promise I'm not trying to do
a gotcha thing like we talked about this
a little bit before we started recording
and I forgot that this study was in the
the journal sweep until like literally
four minutes ago but a couple months ago
there was a study published called
skeletal muscle fiber swelling
contributes to force depression in rats
and humans mechanically skin fiber study
I did see that one and we're asleep yeah
yeah we're essentially they did the same
sort of thing they isolated fibers they
put them in a solution to make them
swell up and then they look to see how
much force they could produce and then
they compressed them to like their
original size again and then had them
and then like electrically stimulated
them again to produce force and it
seemed like force was depressed by like
10 to 15 percent when the fibers were
swollen do you know how swollen like a
percentage o fiber diameter increased by
a hundred and sixteen plus or minus two
percent so that's big swelling well yeah
it is but here's what I'm thinking I
mean it could just be a trade off type
thing where as fibers swell you know
they're they're exerting more
circumferential force against the
sarcolemma which is going to increase
passive tension
but also due to other things the active
tension decreases and so yeah
essentially at that at that point it
would just be a wash yeah
now you say 116 percent that's it
doubled it didn't go up by 16 percent
right it wasn't a hundred and 16 percent
of normal no no no it was a hundred and
sixteen percent of normal for the
diameter diameter increased to one
hundred and sixteen plus or minus two
percent okay what effect would that have
on volume as a percentage this is not a
type of math people when I here live I
mean so it would be it would be diameter
over two times pi the percentage
increase over the original because like
length wouldn't change I wouldn't think
yeah so I mean yeah it it is important
that the the bullfrog study here was
only looking at that passive tension I I
do agree with you I definitely think
that the much more meaningful
contributor is the localized glycogen
depletion within the muscle and its
effects on the actual active force
production right so particularly around
the sarcoplasmic reticulum and there
there's plenty of evidence from animal
models suggesting that those Depot's of
glycogen are depleted early in the
process of muscle depletion I definitely
don't think this is a key contributor
but I'm gonna have to look at that study
about swelling and try to square that
circle and try to figure out what's
going on here at a time when I have
literally nothing else to do and can
focus on it fully
okay so we'll pick this topic back up
and probably eight or nine months yeah
but I don't know I think it's it's
definitely fascinating and I wonder and
I would love to see a human study on
that just like guys who are about to
enter prep just take a bunch of measures
of all their stuff before they start
prep and then like the week before the
show yeah and just see like how much
weaker did they get and what changes are
associated with that yeah cuz because I
mean you know Helms reviewed that study
not long ago we're even
short-term carb load in bodybuilders
before the competition even without
necessarily a focused depletion phase
before it had really I mean it had
meaningful changes on muscle thickness
in cross sectional area I forget which
one they looked at but in any case like
we can see that that that those morphic
morphological changes in the muscle in
terms of their their acute size it
changes within realistic different
nutritional parameters you know
different interventions and so the
question is what effect might that have
on their performance in the gym outside
of just having more glycogen around like
the actual change of the morphology of
the muscle you know how would that
contribute it's so oh who actually so
I'm blanking on the name of the study I
would need to to look for it after after
we get done recording but there was a
really really cool study when I was so I
was just like really obsessed with
[Music]
lateral force transmission and muscles
for a while I remember that yeah so like
muscles don't just contract into end
like they also transmit force into the
connective tissue that runs through the
muscle that's continuous with the tendon
and something like forty to fifty
percent of them of the force of fiber
produces when it contracts is
transmitted laterally to the connective
tissue and not just longitudinally like
in to end and so man there was a paper
maybe like three years ago that modeled
this essentially showing that like as
fibers swell and also just as they
contract because like the the
cross-sectional area of a fiber does is
larger when it's contracted versus not
that that allows it to transmit more
force laterally then then it would be if
the cross-sectional area was less and so
I mean that that may be it because both
of these studies we just talked about
we're looking at either active tension
or passive tension in individual fibers
but then when you
about the system of the entire muscle
and how those fibers would relate to
fibers around them in the connective
tissue it very well could be that when a
fiber gets depleted enough and can't
catch a pump that you know maybe the
effects on active and passive tension of
that fiber itself is essentially a wash
but you might get meaningful effects on
like a decrease in the amount of force
it can transmit laterally to the
connective tissue matrix around it that
strikes me as a potentially plausible
mechanism yeah I could see that we're
gonna have to buy a bunch of condoms and
try to figure it out I guess some
studies cool it sounds like fun awesome
what what what can we stitch the condoms
together with to mimic the connective
tissue matrix well think of something
it'll be fine
okay you know I had another study I want
to talk about but I actually don't want
this to be a 4-hour episode um so here's
a teaser I'm going to talk in a future
episode about comparing plant-based
proteins to way even when the
plant-based proteins are equated in
terms of their leucine content they're
essential amino acid content and their
protein digestibility corrected amino
acid score oh [ __ ] that is thorough yeah
so they corrected just about everything
the result was the plant proteins they
ended up giving a dose of like 33 or 34
grams the way they only gave 24 grams in
order to make all those things corrected
and the way actually outperformed it a
little bit that's the teaser we'll talk
about why in a future episode sounds
like fun yeah people are on the edge of
their seat they're staring at their
calendar right now just wondering how to
pass the time we're gonna get sued by
James Wilks we might what it's just
science man it's hashtag science I guess
okay so I actually had a research thing
to talk about as well yeah I wanted to
make room for your okay cool
so title of the paper I'm looking at is
resistance exercise induced changes in
muscle phenotype our load dependent by
Lin and colleagues and so
essentially this was this was on its
surface in terms of the intervention
itself just another like pretty standard
high load versus low load training study
ten weeks of training one condition
three sets to failure at 80% one set or
other condition three sets to failure at
30% that is that's a pretty standard set
up to look at high load versus low load
training that's been done a lot to this
point this study took it a step further
though where they took muscle biopsies
and looked at a lot of just different
proteins that would affect muscle
structure and function and how those
adapted differently to high load versus
low load training so you know basically
showing that even though total changes
in muscle size were pretty similar which
again they were pretty similar in this
study just as they are in virtually all
of the studies that compare high load
versus low load training they wanted to
see like oh well maybe growth is similar
but what other what what other changes
in in function and phenotype are taking
place that differ between high load and
low load training and so there was some
stuff worth potentially talking about at
some point so there was a larger
increase in the 30 percent group in
mitochondrial proteins associated with
Auto Fei Jie or do you say Auto Fei Jie
or Auto Fuji I say auto fit G okay
that's what I've been hearing more and
more for the life of me I can't
understand why it's not Auto Fei Jie
because that's like Auto is self and Fei
Jie is eat like those should be
different routes I run into this with a
lot of amino acid names like some people
say creatine and some people say
creatine I always find it offensive when
people say creatine mm-hmm but then
there are other amino acids with the
same general like I say theanine but
like there are some amino acids with
that same structure where I pronounced
it the other way and there's no rhyme or
reason to it it's just whatever you feel
like
fair enough so when I'm saying it it's
Paigey because that's what makes the
most sense of the roots so mitochondrial
proteins associated with Otto Fei Jie
fission fusion so basically stuff
associated with mitochondrial
adaptations were larger with the low
load training condition which i think is
what most people would expect but the
thing that I found interesting and the
thing I kind of wanted to pull out of
this study is since they were taking
biopsies and not just looking at
measures of whole muscle you know
increases in thickness or
cross-sectional area it showed changes
in type 1 and type 2 fiber cross
sectional area that's noteworthy because
a lot of people still a lot of people
basically wonder whether load dependent
fiber specific hypertrophy is a thing so
if you train heavier is that gonna grow
your type 2 fibers more and if you train
lighter for higher reps is that going to
grow your type 1 fibers more that's
something that a lot of people believe
and it's still certainly something
that's being debated a lot and it's a
fair question to ask just because
there's not a tremendous amount of data
on that yet to this point so there's a
ton of high load versus low load
training studies and the vast majority
of them only look at changes in whole
muscle size so whole muscle thickness
whole muscle cross sectional area not
that many are taking biopsies to look at
changes in fiber cross sectional areas
and so to this point most of the
research in the area you can interpret
it kind of however you want to depending
on your level of skepticism and what
studies you kind of prioritize or not so
in my opinion the highest quality work
in the area there was a paper from stu
phillips lab it was comparing training
in the 80% to 50% using mostly compound
exercises in i believe people with some
degree of prior training experience
found that type 1 and type 2 fiber
hypertrophy were similar in both the
high load and low load condition there
are a couple other studies with fairly
similar findings there are a pair
papers from a couple Russian researchers
'not Reba and vinaigrette ova that did
find fiber specific hypertrophy with
more type to growth with high-low
training and more type one growth with
low load training and it's probably not
worth getting into them too much now but
there's some there's some some things in
the methods that I don't quite buy about
those studies and if we get into fiber
specific hypertrophy at some point I may
go into that a little bit more but I'm a
little bit skeptical of those studies
but anyway kind of my take is that under
most circumstances load dependent fiber
type specific hypertrophy isn't a thing
or if it is a thing it probably doesn't
occur to a large enough degreed really
worry about and so the reason i wanted
to talk about this study is it it
confirms my biases here
money's much like you wanted to confirm
your biases with the condom study but
we're so above all those other fitness
gurus that are just trying to confirm
all their biases we're way beyond that i
mean at least we can admit it you know
you're allowed to root for it if you if
you call it out right so yeah this one
did look at changes in type 1 and type 2
fiber cross sectional area both fiber
types increased in cross sectional area
in both loading conditions and the
increases were virtually identical
didn't really seem like high low
training was better for type 2 fiber
growth didn't seem like low low training
was better for type 1 fiber growth it is
worth mentioning that in my opinion
there is one really high quality study
that does at least in my opinion show
that under some context load dependent
fiber specific hypertrophy can happen so
there was a study by man I should have
looked this up before we recorded I
think the I think the lead author was
bjornsen but it was a study on power
lifters comparing traditional front
squats to low load front squats with
blood flow restriction over a fairly
short period of time and in that study
they did find a pretty robust type 1
fiber grow
in the group that was doing Lolo
training with blood flow restriction and
only in that group not in the other
group that was doing like heavier
traditional training so I'm not I'm not
close to the idea that load dependent
fiber type specific hypertrophy is is
something that can occur but like in in
that study you know one possibility is
that oh they're power lifters they're
mostly doing heavier stuff maybe they're
type 1 fibers had kind of been maybe
neglected and that there they were kind
of getting like some ketchup growth from
low load training whereas maybe if you
trained with loads and not as similar to
those of a power lifter and more just
like moderate training loads all the
time more like a bodybuilder physique
athlete would do then at that point
maybe you're not really lagging and type
1 fiber growth and so you you know
essentially maybe maybe there are
differences on the extremes that if
you're training with really heavy loads
specific to like what a strength athlete
would be doing maybe you are very
slightly neglecting your type 1 fibers
such that over a period of years you
build up a type 1 hypertrophy deficit
which can then be remedied by a few
weeks of low load training like I think
that's certainly possible but I don't
think it's I don't think it's common
enough to present it as as something
we're just for the general training
populace you do low low training you're
gonna get a lot of type 1 fiber growth
and I don't think that it's in most
circumstances going to be a difference
that's that's practically relevant and
meaningful but yeah so for the most part
I don't think I don't think you need to
worry about doing heavy training to
really work those type ii fibers and
lighter training to really work those
type 1 fibers most if your goal is
hypertrophy unless you have some really
weird and wacky ideas about hypertrophy
training I think the training you just
do normally on a day to day basis is
going to cause pretty robust growth in
both fiber types to a degree that you
don't
need to do extra special training to
target one type or the other that makes
sense to me one of these days we should
take a deeper dive into fiber specific
training and go through some of the
details but that makes sense to me for
sure so I'm holding off because I heard
I heard through the grapevine I don't
know if this is true or not and if it's
not I'm sure he'll let us know but I
heard that Brad was doing a study
looking at high load versus low load
training I think in the soleus versus
the triceps triceps do tend to be a
little type type two dominant soleus is
very very type one dominant I've heard
that a study like that is in the works
so you know I'm sure if that is the case
when it's published a lot of people will
be talking about it and that would be a
good way to couch that discussion but
yeah in general I'm open to the idea
that it exists but I question how
relevant it is under most contexts ya
know it's something we've talked about
this episode is confirmation bias and
various types of bias which is a good
lead-in we've got a drama update and
drama is the new segment that was
created by default because of that one
doping documentary right yeah Lord of
the lifters yeah so we talked a little
bit about a project a while back it was
a series of meta analyses on the health
effects of red meat and processed meat
and some guidelines going along with it
and their their guidelines were
basically a lot less a lot less forceful
than previous guidelines about hey don't
eat fatty red meat don't eat processed
me it's gonna kill you
within the next week or two so they're
like as some of that some of the
research that's leading into those
guidelines is kind of methodological II
not super strong and so we would back
off that not necessarily change the
recommendation but back off in terms of
the certainty with which it's provided
and so that that series of papers caused
a huge stir in the
we talked about it was a listener asked
us hey they found some conflict of
interest from one of these authors of
the guidelines paper does that change
your assessment because our initial
assessment or at least mine I don't want
to speak for you Greg but I was like
yeah I mean we still think that like a
ton of fatty red meat and processed meat
it's like clearly not a great move like
you don't to build your diet around it
but you know low to moderate intakes
probably not the end of the world but
anyway they're like hey does this new
discovered conflict of interest change
your mind and that story has taken a
turn and we've talked about this before
Greg my natural inclination is to take
my hot take freeze it down to a very
cool temperature and present it and this
is one of the instances where I regret
it very much because I played it off as
like oh this this author this Johnston
guy it doesn't seem like a big deal but
whatever yeah we we went lukewarm when
we should have gone nuclear we should
have gone very nuclear and so there's
been a development here there is a JAMA
the Journal of the American Medical
Association they have a blog and there
was a blog post the author's name is
Rita Rubin and it kind of goes into what
happened in the process of this backlash
over the articles that got published so
this is all I'm just kind of I'm not an
investigative journalist I'm not making
any claims here I'm just reporting what
has been published in this blog post and
we're gonna link the blog post if you
want to read it but apparently the
editor and much like our our Godin hero
Bill O'Reilly we're not journalists this
is this is a program purely for
entertainment
exactly so apparently what happened is
the editor-in-chief of the journal that
published these papers saying like
processed meat red meat not the end of
the world they got a flood of angry
emails before the articles even got
published and at one point they they
allegedly received over 2,000 emails in
a 30-minute period and they just like
shut down her inbox and so lame the
editor is she all of those emails were
the same
texts right I think wish I assure it
said that in the article I think they
said it was a bot
yeah which which smells of a bot doing
things yeah and so the editor-in-chief
said like hey we've published about like
firearms and like in preventing injury
from firearms and the National Rifle
Association was way less mid triolic
with their response then the response we
got to this paper about red meat and
processed meat and so there's this group
it's called the true health initiative
it's a non-profit founded by David Katz
you know him from one of the totally
unbiased voices in game changers who was
telling you all about how you know
plants are the only way to live all of
our cinematic universes are just
converging right now it's all yeah it's
all coming into one here we just need
some corrupt weightlifting brass and the
circle would be complete exactly and so
then there's these guys from Harvard
Walter Willett and Frank Hugh that are
on the the council of directors for true
health initiative
now what this journal or this blog post
indicates is that there were these
demands to retract the papers before the
papers were even publicly known which
indicated that their embargo policy had
been violated basically somebody had
gotten access to the press release about
the papers and had basically circulated
that information before they were
supposed to or allowed to and so
basically they're saying that David Katz
was like kind of getting people all
worked up about it and and sharing some
of this embargoed information before he
was allowed to and apparently the
journal dropped him from their list of
journalists that they're willing to
actually send embargoed materials too as
a result and so four days before the
articles were published Katz and eleven
members of the that thi group sent sent
the editor-in-chief a letter saying hey
you got to retract these before they
even go up and apparently according to
this blog post this Katz guy wrote in a
his own kind of article somewhere he
called he called these articles a great
debacle of public health and he compared
them to
he called it information terrorism that
could blow to smithereens the life's
work of innumerable careful scientists I
am a hundred percent going to start
referring to everything I come across I
disagree with as information terrorism I
mean you kind of have to now the
precedent has been set that's um
that's the most melodramatic [ __ ]
I've ever heard
are you kidding me and you're the king
of melodrama you always do it
sarcastically but this one appears to be
for real like that's seriously if you
had a particularly precocious
four-year-old who like you know it isn't
just going to be like I didn't get the
toy I won't I'm going to die like that
it's it sounds like the melodrama you'd
hear from a four-year-old we're like you
know mom says oh you can't have dessert
before dinner it's like that's fake news
that's information terrorism culinary
terrorism yeah that's no dessert Jesus
Christ that's that that is infantile so
okay there's this other group is called
the Physicians Committee for Responsible
medicine they went so far they
petitioned the Federal Trade Commission
the FTC a federal entity to intervene on
these papers and to what they say -
correct false statements and they
actually took it a step beyond that they
asked the district attorney for the city
of Philadelphia to intervene to
investigate potential reckless
endangerment resulting from publishing
this work well I mean that's how science
is done you may think that the ideal
remedy to science is you know the peer
review process and if you think people
are doing shoddy work find holes in
their actual methodology and what they
did and correct it or do better work
that supersedes but that's actually a
complete lie that's that's in fact
information terrorism science is done in
the Philadelphia district attorney's
office that is how that's how you
settled scientific disputes now I
suppose goddamn this is this the the
where this goes on the better it gets
yeah it's so the this this group the the
PCRM that they described their mission
as saving and improving improving human
and animal lives through plant-based
diets and ethical and effective research
methods so like there they've got if
they've they've shown their cards right
now this whole dust-up this whole thing
of reviewing Johnston's he was a the
kind of a senior author on the original
papers reviewing his conflicts of
interest they said they made a big deal
about him getting money from a group
called Texas A&M agrilife so it's a
funding mechanism associated with Texas
A&M University that did receive money
from the big bad beef industry turns out
the beef industry provides about 1.5
percent of Agri life's total funding and
about half of Agri lives funding comes
from federal sources it's just like the
USDA you know the agriculture related
entities like they have stuff about like
I said if you go to their homepage it's
a bunch of like crops and stuff they're
talking about like pesticides and cotton
and like materials and honestly dog I'm
kind of disappointed in AgriLife for
this
it's they're associated with Texas A&M
that's a Texas University and only one
and a half percent is coming from the
beef industry they got to pump those
numbers up yeah that is positively
untaxed and of them yeah this is kind of
a big I think this is the real scan
detected where is the beef industry I
mean come on so um in any case that this
blog post like I said I'm just relaying
to you what's in this thing but it goes
all through Katz's background and you
know they kind of said like we'll do it
you've had like several big grants from
from groups and you work with companies
that are for-profit and and they just
kind of be like okay so you and like
people from you know I talked about
Willett and Hugh they're from Harvard
School of Public Health and they're like
you guys all seem to get funding from
like you know some kind of like walnut
group and all kinds of like different
like plant-based kind of
foundations and funding sources and and
so I think they attribute this quote to
Katz he's like I don't think you can
accuse you know so-and-so of conflict of
interest they have a genuine interest in
the health effects of nuts there's
nothing fundamentally wrong with
industry funding which would be fine if
he didn't previously attack Johnston
based on having funding from a group
that got one and a half percent of their
funding from the beef industry and so
he's like he's basically making the
argument you know we study this stuff
because we love it he's studying this
stuff because he's crooked and paid off
by big beef doot-doot-doot the next
quote that you have on here because this
is the most this is the most like law
URI [ __ ] I've ever heard this is
this is on on tier with like the Bill
Clinton impeachment trial like it
depends what is is like yeah this is
this is good [ __ ] yeah so according to
the blog post he told JAMA I think there
was a big difference between conflict of
interest versus a confluence of interest
the work you do is what you care about
no one's ever paid me to say anything I
don't believe you could screenshot that
and then if you just like looked looked
up in the dictionary the definition of
distinction without a difference you
could just include that screenshot and
that's literally what it is yeah and so
in this jam a blog post they mention all
the like you know six hundred seven
hundred thousand dollar grants that that
cats has previously received to do
various nutrition studies on like the
effect of cocoa on vascular function and
the health effects of eggs and again
they're they're funded by companies that
produce chocolate or or you know promote
egg consumption and stuff like that and
so the article like I said we're gonna
link it go ahead and read through it
make your own decisions but I think it
is really telling based on social media
posts it sounds like DNA how does he
pronounced his name Stefan I think so
so Stefan DNA he kind of went out on on
social media I forget which platform but
he basically was like whitter L on
Twitter yeah he's like I was really
disappointed to read this article it's
the blog post that we're referring to
describing attempts by the the thi to
suppress
these meta-analyses as a result of this
I've cut my ties with thi obviously I
paraphrased and abbreviated there but
basically he was like I'm not on board
with this based on what I'm seeing in
this blog post I I don't like how this
went down I'm out and he mentioned this
isn't about whose opinions on red meat
are right or wrong it's about the
integrity of the scientific method
I hope thi can find a better path
forward
Jonnie freed HOF he also was previously
associated with the thi in some capacity
and he posted somewhere you know shared
Stefan's disappointment also cut my ties
so which honestly like that's a big deal
to me because I mean I I don't follow
nutrition research super closely but
Gihon a and Fred HOF are both people who
at least I perceived to be super legit
and also just from following them over
the years like they both seem like great
dudes with strong moral compasses and
also the furthest thing one could
possibly be from like a pro red meat
slash processed meat extremist yeah
yeah and so this alone was enough to be
like wow that's really fascinating but
then this happened which totally blew my
mind so the Chancellor of the Texas A&M
University System so Texas A&M and all
the branch campuses that the basically
top executive with that entity had an
open letter to the president of Harvard
again that's where two of those
researchers are Willett and Hugh and
basically it's an open letter will link
it in in the the show notes as well so
you can read it but basically the
chancellor of texas A&M is calling on
harvard Harvard's president he's like
dude look at the allegations in this
JAMA blog post like you need to get this
stuff together you need to investigate
you know what's going on with your
faculty members cuz you know the way he
said it was you know the the Chancellor
of Texas A&M is under the impression
that these two people mischaracterized
scientific research and falsely accused
Texas A&M scientists of selling out to
industry interests and so I mean this is
like a red-hot on the academic spectrum
of vitriol and just general infighting
like this is like this is a big deal I
mean it sounds like they're going to
find out that science can not just be
adjudicated in the DA's office of
Philadelphia but also the DA's office of
College Station Texas okay that sounds
like where it's going I don't think
it'll go that far I think it's a lot of
I think the Texas A&M folks were just
like alright enough is enough like get
it together I don't think this is really
gonna play out into anything huge but I
mean it is at least bordering on
defamation of character
I mean potentially uh potentially so
again we're gonna we're gonna post the
links in the show notes to the Jama blog
post and also that open letter from the
chancellor of texas A&M
I'm just faithfully reporting what's in
the blog post I didn't like go through
in fact check every single part of this
because I trust that that JAMA is not
gonna go on to some smear campaign with
a bunch of fake news I feel that would
be a very bad choice for them but in any
case that's the state of the the current
scandal related to red meat and
processed meat as I said before I didn't
think that potential conflict of
interest from Johnston was anything
troubling or out of the ordinary and by
the way I don't fault cats will it Hugh
I don't fault any of them for taking
private industry funding mechanisms for
their research I don't fault any of them
for doing that however if you do take
those types of grants you can't
immediately turn around and say that
anyone who takes industry funded grants
is therefore a crook you can't really do
that you know you my my rule is I
support all researchers taking private
industry grants and faithfully and
transparently doing research with them
you have to be consistent with it know
for sure so the thing that got me was
just that [ __ ] quote like there's a
difference between a conflict of
interest and a confluence of interest
it's like what do you think what do you
think these [ __ ] are doing
do you think he took money from the
AgriLife Institute in spite of the fact
that he hates all agriculture like yeah
what do you think's going on there I
hate the concept of food therefore I
can't take money from anyone who does
anything with food well food and
probably textiles too I think they have
a lot of cotton related stuff as well so
I mean that's at least understandable
yeah but anyway so that that is the
state of the scandal and I still think I
don't know I just don't eat a ton of
processed meats but maybe you can eat a
little bit oh that's the hot take all
right so that that sums up that segment
yes okay so we're about to move on to
the to play us out segment but before
that we need to thank our sponsor which
funded the drama segment of this episode
the National Cattlemen's Beef
Association thanks I love the work
they're doing by the way I would say
this is a clear confluence of interest
situation love cattlemen love beef just
love everything about it
yeah okay so to play us out let's talk
about sourdough bread so if you've been
following me on Instagram you know I've
been getting really into bread baking
recently and I recently made the shift
over to sourdough and so sourdough is is
good I personally think it's tasty and
for some people who have like fodmap
sensitivities sourdough bread is a lot
more digestible and causes less stomach
problems than bread made with commercial
yeast because basically to make
sourdough work it needs a longer
fermentation time and that allows time
to break down a lot of those compounds
that people with fodmap sensitivities
struggle to digest so it's you know
theoretically maybe a little bit
healthier I think subjectively it's much
more delish
and if he struggled with bread just
consuming it and not having GI issues
sourdough may be good for you whereas
conventionally baked bread wanted so
anyway that's just some background about
sourdough so here here's some sourdough
tips if you want to get into baking
sourdough bread at home so to start with
if you want to do a real sourdough bread
you need a sourdough starter what I mean
by real sourdough bread is you can make
a cheating version a pale simulacrum of
sourdough bread by basically just adding
vinegar or something sour to regular
bread dough some of the acetic acid from
the vinegar will stick around and leave
the bread tasting sour that is
apparently how at least some like
mass-manufactured sourdough bread does
it just by adding sour things into the
dough instead of using a natural
sourdough starter but if you want to
make a real sourdough bread that means
you need a sourdough starter and that's
essentially just a mixture of flour and
water that picks up yeast and lactic
acid bacteria the yeast come from the
flower itself it's just hanging out on
the flower and small amounts and then it
gets to work breaking down the sugars
and multiplies and you have a nice
little colony of yeast and the lactic
acid bacteria as I understand it comes
from the air like from the environment
and doesn't come with the flour so you
need to get it you need to get a starter
going there's a lot of articles online
about how to maintain a starter it's
pretty straightforward you just discard
about two-thirds to half of it every day
and then feed it by adding equal parts
in mass wise of flour and water to it
mix it up let it go another 24 hours
dump half of it out add flour and water
again and once the starter is stable and
healthy you can keep it alive like that
virtually forever but the challenging
part where the starter is getting and
going in the first place and I've
actually tried to make sourdough breads
several times before but the thing I
always struggled with was getting a
healthy and productive starter going
in the issues so the issues you can run
into is either one not getting enough
lactic acid bacteria in the the starter
mix early enough or not getting enough
yeast and early enough because basically
once you get enough lactic acid bacteria
in the mix and once you get enough yeast
in the mix they form a symbiotic
relationship where you know they break
down different parts of the flower they
liberate food for the other ones to
consume it's a nice big happy family and
they also both like acidic conditions so
a pH somewhere between three point five
to five and once the pH drops to that
level that keeps harmful bacteria from
being able to grow so if pH gets too
high you could get an infection with
botulinum toxin and that can kill you
and that's not good do you want a
relatively low pH and so I struggled
with this before because essentially I'd
get to work on the feeding for a few
days and then I think basically there
just wasn't enough yeast in the flour I
was using or I wasn't getting quick
enough culturing of the lactic acid
bacteria to kill off the bad stuff and I
just get kind of like a fungal
overgrowth that would start in the in
the container where I was making my
starter which really wasn't pretty so I
did some reading and I did some testing
and I came up with a solution that at
least for me got me a starter that was
already like bubbly healthy and stable
within like two or three days which
previously I'd been working for like two
weeks and couldn't get it stable so what
worked really really well for me is to
start with instead of just starting with
flour and water which is what most
people recommend instead of water for
the first few days when you feed your
starter use kefir which you might call
kefir I learned that I was pronouncing
that wrong it is kefir or a mixture of
yogurt and water the the kefir or the
yogurt and water will contain lactic
acid bacteria assuming you're using
unpasteurized which you should be
so that'll infuse lactic acid bacteria
into the mixture make sure you have a
bunch of those to start with and yogurt
and kefir also have a pretty good pH for
sour dough so they'll have a pH
somewhere between about four to four and
a half which is in the range of three
and a half to five that you want for
your sourdough environment so that takes
care of the lactic acid bacteria and it
starts taking care of the pH and then
another thing you can do if you know if
you're using a flour that just doesn't
have enough yeast on it to to really
start colonizing your starter fast
enough is you can actually use a tiny
bit of commercial yeast so maybe just
like in eighth of a teaspoon or a
quarter teaspoon and that's a neat
little hack because the thing that had
kept me from doing that before is like I
wanted the natural yeast flavor to be
able to pump out the lactic acid and
acetic acid and high enough quantities
that I would want for a nice sour
sourdough bread and you don't get that
from commercial yeast commercial yeast
will basically just produce co2 and
ethanol and doesn't produce nearly as
much lacked or nearly as much lactic
acid or acetic acid but I was doing some
reading and it turns out commercial
yeast is kind of like the flame that
burns bright and burns out fast so it's
not very it's not very hearty if you're
feeding a mixture only once every 24
hours commercial yeast will basically
spinned itself and die in less than 24
hours at room temperature and since it's
just less hardy than wild-type yeast if
you have a culture that has both wild
type and commercial yeast over time the
wild type yeast will out-compete the
commercial yeast so you can use a little
commercial yeast in your initial mixture
along with the kefir for the lactic acid
bacteria to get that sim symbiosis going
between the yeast and the lactic acid
bacteria to create the conditions you
want for a stable healthy starter and
then over time the natural yeast will
out-compete the commercial yeast to take
over the culture and so then you have a
nice stable happy starter so if if you
ever tried making sourdough before and
you weren't able to get a good starter
going you can try some of those tips so
again instead of just using water your
first couple of days use kefir or a
mixture of yogurt and water as you're
feeding your starter and then also try
mixing a tiny little bit of commercial
yeast and to start with those those two
tips at least did the trick for me and
within like I said two or three days I
had a stable starter and within like
four or five days it was a good good
sourdough starter you know it smelled
the way you wanted to it's behaving
predictably it's it's good good stuff
one final little note is you want to
make sure that you're feeding it with
unbleached flour instead of bleached
flour and ideally at least some degree
of whole wheat as well bleached white
flour has lower levels of natural yeast
on it so it just takes longer for
everything to get to get rolling and the
whole wheat flour like the other stuff
in the flour the yeast likes munching on
so either like 50/50 unbleached white
flour and whole wheat flour just all
whole wheat flour it's gonna be ideal
for for feeding your starter or rye
flour apparently the the natural yeast
and lactic acid bacteria like rye the
most so anyway those are tips for
getting your starter going and then just
general tips for the bread itself is so
everything I'm about to say I'm sure is
old hat for people who have a lot of
experience
baking with sourdough but for me like
I'm just getting into it I've turned out
about six loaves at this point and the
last four of them have been really good
the first two were kind of sketchy the
thing I ran into with the first couple
of loaves is they were good but they
just tasted like normal ass bread uh-huh
and I wanted sourdough because I wanted
it to taste sour like I liked that sour
taste and the thing I ran into is
essentially I was I was playing with kid
gloves with fermentation times and when
you're normally cooking bread with
commercial yeast you know
you mix everything up you let it rise
for an hour maybe an hour and a half if
the rooms kind of cold you punch it down
you shape the loaf let it rise for about
another hour again and it's good to go
so you're kind of used to going from
mixing to baking in about a three hour
period or if you [ __ ] in the fridge
overnight you know it might take another
like two hours to wake up and rise when
you bring it back to room temp but it's
a fairly fast process with sourdough the
timeline is dramatically longer so if
you just take commercial yeast and mix
up dough and let it sit at room
temperature for 12 hours it's going to
be completely useless at that point but
something like 10 to 12 hours is a
pretty good starting point for making
sourdough obviously you can differ if
you are using refrigeration to [ __ ]
the dough and maybe let a little bit
more flavor develop but if you want to
do the whole thing at room temp if you
go ahead and mix the dough and you know
maybe do some turns and folds to develop
some gluten strength but basically just
let it sit at room temp for minimum
eight hours but really like twelve is a
decent starting point and up to 18 like
the best loaf I've made so far was just
hanging out at room temp for about 18
and a half hours before I popped it in
the oven that was good ass bread so to
get away with that you want to make sure
that in your original recipe the starter
is a relatively low percentage of the
total flour you're working with so the
loaves I make I go with 600 grams of
flour so my starter I keep it at like
66% hydration so I add a hundred grams
of starter which is about or yeah which
is about 60 grams of flour or so so
about 10% of the flour going into my
finished loaf is from the starter it's
going to take longer for that to like
fully inoculate and ferment the dough if
you go with a higher percentage of
starter so if say like 20-25 percent of
the total flour going into your loaf was
from your starter that's going to be
able to
ferment the dough much much faster and
so maybe you'll be able to pop that loaf
in the oven in like five or six hours
which shortens your baking time but it
also doesn't give as much time for
flavor to develop that's one of the
things I did with one of the first
loaves I think I went with like 22%
flour from the starter and the loaf
turned out well like it had the texture
that I wanted and everything was was
generally nice but it didn't have that
intense sour flavor so you want to go
with a relatively low percentage of
flour coming from the starter again
maybe like 10 percent or so and try to
aim for a dough that can hang out like I
said for like 10 12 hours plus that'll
give you enough time for really really
intense sour flavor development doing
some reading about this it basically
seems like early on lactic acid is the
main thing that those yeasts well both
the east and the lactic acid bacteria
are producing I guess more the lactic
acid bacteria but as the fermentation
goes longer and longer and longer
those lactic acid bacteria will pump out
more acetic acid and lactic acid will
taste like kind of sour and tangy if
it's present in high enough quantities
like say in kefir or yogurt but you're
probably gonna have a pretty hard time
getting enough lactic acid in bread
dough for it to have a really really
intense effect on flavor so it's really
the acetic acid that's going to give it
that characteristic sour sour dough
flavor and to get that you really need
long fermentation times so yeah don't be
scared don't think on the timelines that
you would with commercial yeast if
you're used to mixing and then baking
three hours later you're not even in the
right ballpark it's probably gonna be at
least twice that long and again if your
room is fairly cool and you're using a
relatively low percentage of flour
coming from your starter it could go 12
18 hours before you bake so it's a
slower process it's a little bit more
while it's considerably more time
intensive but you're gonna get a lot
more flavorful loaf from it I don't feel
comfortable necessarily sharing a recipe
just because like
everything is going to be very strongly
dependent on like what type of yeast and
what type of bacteria are in your
starter are you using white or
whole-grain flour for the loaf what
temperature is your kitchen
are you retarding the dough in the
fridge overnight like there's a lot of
variables you can play with but just in
general those would be my
recommendations like start with a low
percentage from a low percentage of
total flour from your starter and and
give it time
basically what I would recommend is like
kind of allow a loaf to overproof and
work backwards from there so like if you
find that at 24 hours your the dough is
over proofed it doesn't rise right like
it falls in the oven then you know work
backwards you find that like okay 20
hours maybe it's a little over proof but
it's generally alright work back a
little bit further 18 hours it's not
over proofed it's great like then
somewhere in the 16 to 18 hour range
should be what you aim for just like
lifting a lot of it's a troubleshooting
process especially when you're working
with sourdough cuz you know you're
you're trying to coax life and flavor
out of living organisms which is going
to be somewhat unpredictable but it's
gonna be a troubleshooting process but
just in general the the process you can
find to work with that gives you the
longest total fermentation time is
what's gonna produce the most intense
and in my opinion the best flavor
yeah and I've tried your sourdough bread
it was very very good I don't know which
loaf I got but I assume it's one of the
four good ones you got the second good
one okay the fourth is downstairs right
now it's the best Oh interesting you
should grab a slice on the way out the
door
I should alright well that does it for
this episode I can say this pretty
confidently we basically have three
kinds of listeners so if you came here
for reckless speculation about self
swelling and frog muscle or if you came
here for sourdough bread tips or if you
came here just for nutrition related
beefs between academics you got
something that you are interested in we
got all those
is covered today so that does it for
this week's episode as always thank you
for listening and we will see you next
time thanks for listening to the
stronger by science podcast now Greg and
I are not experts in medicine or health
or really anything else for that matter
so before you make any changes to your
diet and exercise habits make sure you
check with a doctor or another
healthcare professional if you enjoyed
this podcast and you'd like to support
it visit stronger by science com2 check
out the products and services that we
offer thanks for listening and we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you